Ja, zumindest habe ich mir jetzt dieses schicke Notizbuch gekauft, aber ich habe irgendwie noch nicht angefangen, da was reinzuschreiben.
Aber dieses Bullet Journal Konzept ist eigentlich ganz geil, zumindest wenn du die Icons ein bisschen anpasst, die Symbolik anpasst.
Das Beste ist das komplett zu forken für dich selbst.
Ja genau, es ist quasi ein Hoodie.
Du gehst doch gleich mit dem Repro aufgetab, warum nicht?
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Zumindest, was ich immer mache,
fängst du natürlich ganz normal
mit dem Datum an, dass du das irgendwie
sortiert hast. Du musst es dir in der Zukunft
eh nicht nochmal angucken. Aber so die
drei wichtigsten Sachen, die ich mache, ich schreibe mir jetzt hier
was Neues auf. Ich mache mir vorne so ein Karo
rein. Da steht dann Nullnummer.
Das kann ich irgendwann abhaken.
Das zweite Task ist Kindle-Kabel
erklären.
Dritte Task, äh, Quatsch,
Kindle-Kabel zurückgeben. Dritte Task
ist
Hoodie-Journal erklären.
Auf deinen eigenen Fork
des Bullet Journals eingehen. Genau.
Und danach müsste ich noch
ein Müll rausbringen.
Eine Sache, die im Übrigen sehr gefiel an dem
Bullet Journal Konzept von dieser
YouTuberin, deren Namen ich komplett vergessen habe.
Ich glaube, dass sie Schuhe macht, die Highfields
heißen. Ich höre keine Rolle.
Die macht
vorne in ihre Kästchen, von die
To-Dos, eine Art Ladebalken. Die malt
die ein bisschen aus. Die hat wohl vorher
kompletten Balken über die ganze Breite gemalt.
meinte aber, dass sie keinen Bock hat,
so viel auszumalen.
Und malte einfach prozedurell voll,
wie die Meinung ist, wie sie damit den Tag fertig ist.
Einen kurzen Strich vorne, sie hat gerade angefangen,
den halben vollmalen, sie ist gerade mittendrin
und mal das Ding aus, wenn du fertig bist.
Und du kannst auch sehen, wo der Fortschritt ungefähr liegt.
Also ich habe jetzt die ganz normalen Kästchen,
ich habe jetzt hier fünf Tätigkeiten reingeschrieben,
ich habe fünf leere Kästchen vorne dran
und eigentlich wollte ich dir bloß zeigen,
was ich dann damit mache.
Ich könnte jetzt also sagen,
Hoodie Journal erklären habe ich jetzt fertig,
das kreuze ich jetzt einfach durch.
Müll rausbringen.
Das breche ich ab, das mache ich nicht.
Das streiche ich gerade durch.
Einfach strich mitten durch.
Show Notes mache ich später.
Da kommt hier so ein Pfeil raus.
Für die Mitte nach rechts raus.
Für Delayed.
Und dann gehst du später nochmal durch.
Und wenn du so ein Teil siehst, musst du halt auf der nächsten Seite
am nächsten Tag das Ding nochmal hinschreiben.
Machst du dann einfach ein leeres Kässchen oder machst du ein Pfeil rein von außen?
Dann kannst du dann, ich glaube,
bei Show The Journal ging dann so ein Pfeil
nach links raus, dass das irgendwie
oder von links rein.
Dass es zumindest klar ist, dass...
Genau. Und dann für normale Notizen
mache ich dann einfach so einen Kreis,
dass du da nichts, womit du interagieren musst.
Achso, das ist dann alles in der Liste einfach.
So hier Notes.
Also du nutzt es wirklich als Braindump.
Das ist, ja, Getting Things Done. Einfach, sobald du es aufgeschrieben hast,
hast du den Kopf wieder frei, sonst
das ist eigentlich das Wichtigste, dass du es aus dem Kopf raus hast.
Eben.
Und dann kannst du später nochmal drüber gehen,
ob du es machen willst oder nicht.
Das klingt auch super.
Genau. Und weitere Symbolik
kann man später noch einfach...
Ich glaube, einen Vorschrift brauchst du nicht unbedingt.
Ja, und man kann es nutzen.
Du kannst es ja trotzdem ausmalen oder machst ein X rein,
wie es dir gefällt, aber man kann halt auch dieses Fortschritt-Icon...
Genau, also das muss ich mir mal angucken.
Das habe ich mir jetzt hier
aufgeschrieben unter...
Das ist eigentlich eine Aufgabe unter Show Notes.
Alternative
Bullet
Okay, ja.
War das jetzt Thema 1 für unsere erste Folge des tollen Podcasts?
Achso, ja stimmt, wir nehmen ja einen Podcast auf.
Die Aufnahme läuft schon seit dreieinhalb Minuten.
Und wir haben überhaupt keine Gedanken uns darüber gemacht,
was wir eigentlich besprechen wollen.
Wir haben einfach mal die Aufnahme gestartet und waren mittendrin.
Aber offenbar sprechen wir auf Deutsch.
Ja, stimmt.
Wir hatten kurz darüber gesprochen, ob wir auf Englisch sein wollen.
Aber haben einfach nicht weiter darüber gesprochen.
Vielleicht machen wir einfach irgendwann mal eine Folge auf Englisch.
Also das Konzept, was mir so ein bisschen vorschwebte,
Ich meine, dadurch, dass ich jetzt nicht mehr jeden Tag
an der Uni bin und du auch nicht
und wir uns halt nicht mehr so häufig sehen,
die Gespräche sind ja trotzdem relativ
ergiebig gewesen.
Du weißt, wo wir gestern über Haskell abgerätet hatten?
Ja, also gestern wäre es echt
super gewesen,
weil wir uns so, nachdem wir uns eine Woche nicht gesehen haben,
wir treffen uns
und starten sofort die Aufnahme.
Das machen wir nächstes Mal.
Ich gehe los mit Hey Sexy.
Und
dann ist der Podcast quasi
Nennen wir ihn SexyCast oder so.
Wir brauchen noch einen Namen.
Ich glaube, wenn ihr das jetzt hört, dann habt ihr das nicht unter
sexycast.fm runtergeladen.
Nee, das Sexy ist übrigens eine Art
Insider, was heißt Insider, mittlerweile nicht mehr wirklich
Insider, weil ich Hendrik zum Geburtstag, also das
ist übrigens Hendrik, ich bin Kilian,
zum Geburtstag vor ein paar Jahren
mal die Domain Hendrik.sexy gekauft habe.
Das war super lieb von dir.
Kurz ein paar Tage später schrieb mich
Hendrik an mit, schau mal auf Kilian.sexy und seitdem
gehören uns gegenseitig die.sexy-Domains
mit dem Vornamen des anderen.
Wie ist jetzt natürlich sinnvoll genutzt,
mit einem sexy Foto.
Ich kann aber in meinem auch nichts aussetzen.
Und seitdem
begrüßen wir uns auch immer mit HeySexy.
Und andere Leute finden das super toll, wenn sie merken,
dass Hendrik und Kilian.sexy
existieren. Es existiert nicht Hendrik und Kilian.sexy.
Ich habe den Eindruck, wir haben die übelste Bromance am Laufen.
Das ist ein bisschen übertrieben.
Aber warum eigentlich nicht?
Ja, ansonsten sind wir zwei
Nerds und Hacker.
Das Intro nach 5 Minuten machen.
Wer es jetzt noch mithört, vielen Dank.
Hier wollte das Intro, genau.
Und wir sind
zwei sehr unterschiedliche Typen und deswegen
ergeben sich eigentlich auch immer ganz
spannende Gespräche.
Kean
nerdert immer sehr gerne über Swift
und wir nerd allgemein sehr gerne über
Programmiersprachen rum und lästern.
Wahrscheinlich viel über Sprachen reden.
Ich glaube, wir werden viel über Programmiersprachen reden.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so leise macht.
Ich glaube,
Ich schreibe mir jetzt mal auf.
Also 5 Minuten 47
hört man mich.
Ich werde auf jeden Fall den Podcast
danach schön in Kapitel splitten.
Womit machst du das eigentlich?
Mit einem Tool, was ich vorhin
entdeckt habe. Ne, das stimmt gar nicht.
Fischen nutze ich schon länger. Fischen heißt das Tool, ist ein Mac-Up.
Zum schnell zurechtschreiten
von Audiodateien.
Ist ungefähr so gut wie Audacity.
Was heißt so gut wie? Von der Optik her
funktioniert es ähnlich wie Audacity.
Es ist nicht so hässlich wie Audacity.
oder Audio City, wie Professor Weber,
einer unserer Profs. der Informatikfakultät,
sozusagen pflegt. Audio City.
Es ist nicht so herzlich
wie Audacity. Es sieht ähnlich aus von der Optik her.
Es ist eine generative Make-up und
kann leider nicht Rauschunterdrückung,
wie ich es vorhin gemerkt habe.
Aber es kann wunderbar toll ein Kapitel
schneiden, das Ganze als chapterized MP3
exportieren. Und vor allem kannst du sogar
für jedes Kapitel, das habe ich bei einem Podcast
öfter mal gesehen, ATP,
den Accidental Tech Podcast,
Die haben oft für einzelne...
Fast eigentlich zu uns.
Ja genau, eigentlich Exzenzl Sexy Cast.
Haben die für einzelne Kapitel in dem Podcast einzelne Artwork-Dateien, die angepasst sind auf die Kapitel.
Das ist halt mega nervig, wenn ich dann auf mein iPhone schaue und merke, ach shit, das Kapitel hat schon wieder ein anderes Bild.
Und ich habe es vielleicht verpasst für die letzten drei Kapitel, weil ich nicht bei jedem Kapitel in mein iPhone aus der Tasche ziehe.
Das gibt es dann irgendwie Player, die das auf der Zeitleiste visualisieren.
Das wäre natürlich cool.
Aber ich muss sagen, mein Podcast-Player,
ich muss mir mal einen neuen suchen für Android,
der kann nicht mehr, der unterstützt nicht mehr Kapitelmarken.
Keine Kapitelmarken.
Der ist super schön, aber ich habe mal eine Zeit lang Antenna-Pod benutzt,
das kann Kapitelmarken, aber da kannst du nicht mehr als 10 Podcasts mitverwalten,
weil die Verwaltung von Episoden und von Feeds ist einfach nicht...
Ich kenne auch niemanden, der so viele Podcasts hört wie dich.
Also ich dachte, ich höre ganz viele.
Ich glaube, ich bin bei 15, 20, 25 Stück,
aber du bist ja ein Gefühl, die 100 haben.
Ja, ich komme auch nicht wirklich bei allen hinterher.
Ich kann mich aber einfach nicht trennen irgendwann.
Ja klar, man hat irgendwie mal verpasst sonst was.
Ich bin immer ganz schwer, einzelne Folgen zu löschen, bevor ich sie gehört habe.
Es geht aber sehr selten.
Das ist halt das Schöne bei
BeyondPod, was ich benutze.
Da kannst du halt sagen, okay, von dem
Feed hol dir
immer die aktuellsten, wenn du WLAN hast
und behalte aber bloß
1 oder 5 oder 10.
Die fallen automatisch weg, wenn du siehst.
Ja, die fallen
automatisch hinten wieder raus.
Da muss ich nicht irgendwie selber drüber laufen
und das löschen. Und es gibt auch einfach
diese schöne Kategorie, die automatisch
das aktuellste einfach zusammen mischte.
Die heißt What to Play oder What to...
Und dann kannst du dir einfach...
Das ist halt das, was der schön macht.
Der ist halt gut dafür gedacht, dass man
ganz viel
Binge hört.
Aber
Kapitelmarken kann er immer noch nicht.
Das ist schade. Das geht bei mir ein bisschen manuell an.
Mit Overcast für iOS.
Ich dampe einfach 98%
der Podcasts, die ich höre in einer Playliste,
die heißt Listen.
Ein Podcast ist als Priority-Podcast
markiert, das heißt, dessen Folgen landen immer vorne
an der ganze erste, wenn da neue
Folgen rauskommen. Und zwei Podcasts
landen eben nicht in dieser Playliste,
weil ich die einzeln höre. Und das eine von denen ist
Hardcore History, ein großartiger Podcast,
aber die Folgen sind halt viereinhalb Stunden lang
und die möchte ich dann gerne
hören, wenn ich mal, keine Ahnung, längerfristig in der
Bade zu dem Flugzeug oder sonst wo. Ich hab mir mal
die Serie über
Genghis Khan angenommen. Oh, das war
ein fantastischer. Oh, das war so großartig.
Leider ist das nicht mehr in den Viererhältnissen.
Weil die alten Folgen rausschmeißen
Du findest die Genghis Khan-Folgen nicht mehr.
Die musst du wahrscheinlich irgendwo im Internet bestimmen,
aber die sind nicht mehr direkt im Backlog von dem Feed.
Krass. An dieser Stelle könnten wir
vielleicht, wo wir gerade eh über Podcasts rumnerden,
da könnte man mal
bei Bitlove nachgucken. Stimmt.
Bitlove. Das ist alles über Torrent,
was du da teilst, oder? Ja, aber der hat
irgendwo eine Kiste stehen, die das, ich weiß nicht,
wie viel Platz die hat. Du meinst, der archiviert
alles und da kriegt man im Nachhinein... Ja, der ist erst mal
Seeder von, der Server ist erst mal
Seeder von sich aus. Ach so, über HCP-Seeding?
Ne, über Torrent.
Die Frage ist,
was noch schön wäre,
das Problem ist, dass es für Bitlove,
soweit ich weiß, immer noch keinen
Client gibt, außer Miro.
Weil die nicht die klassischen URLs haben, wo du einfach
per RSS oder HTTP Downloads das dann runterziehen kannst?
Naja, von Bitlove kannst du nur
Torrents runterziehen.
Es geht nur Torrent.
Miro konnte das, aber es ist ein ganz schönes
Funstab. Fürs Telefon gibt es, glaube ich, nichts,
soweit ich weiß. Aber übrigens, an dieser Stelle,
ihr könnt es, wenn ihr Podcast-Klient-Tipps
dann schickt uns die.
Ich bin ganz glücklich, aber Hendrik braucht ja was für Hendrik.
Naja, ganz ehrlich,
ich bin mit BeyondPod zufrieden,
wenn es noch Chapter Max könnte
und BitTorrent wäre super.
Aber BitTorrent...
Das ist halt ein hartes Feature.
Keine Frage, wäre das klasse, aber das ist...
Ich meine, wir nutzen sowas außer BitLove.
Was eigentlich noch geiler wäre fast
für Podcasts...
Wäre erstmal eine App-Idee, ein BitLove-Client schreiben?
Du musst doch bestimmt schon was jemand mal probiert haben
oder angegangen sein.
Naja, die Idee hatte ich schon vor vier Jahren.
kommen nicht dazu.
Man müsste da mal was programmieren.
Das ist auf dem Kongress, ist einer mit dem T-Jet rumgelaufen.
Natürlich, klassisch.
Was noch cool wäre für Podcasts, wäre IPFS.
Uh, niemals verschwindende Podcast-Folgen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Für immer gemirrert im IPFS, im Interplanetary File System.
Auf jeden Fall, ja.
Das ist auch ein krasses Projekt.
Da müssen wir mal, glaube ich, ein bisschen länger drüber reden.
Ich kenne mich mit IPFS auch nicht so gut aus, du umso mehr.
Also bedeutet mehr als ich zumindest.
Weniger, ja.
Aber die Media-CCC-Leute haben die gesamten...
Das ist alles in IPFS?
Die haben in IPFS-Mirror aufgemacht.
Im Endeffekt machst du ein Mirror auf.
Du hast ja bloß einen Node davon, von diesem Netzwerk.
Ja, das verteilt sich, glaube ich, nicht von alleine.
Ach so, du musstest tatsächlich irgendwo durchpushen, dein Content?
Du musstest irgendwie...
Wenn ihr jetzt tieferer Einblicke in IPFS von mir erwartet,
dann muss ich euch leider enttäuschen.
Das machen wir vielleicht bei einer nächsten Runde nochmal.
Das schauen wir uns mal an.
Die IPFS schreibe ich mir mal auf.
Ich durchbreche ständig die
Fourth Wall hier bei uns.
Als ob wir eine hätten.
Nee, aber
was noch eine schöne Alternative
dazu ist, zu IPFS, ist das
Network, hier Safe Network
von Made Safe.
Da ist es tatsächlich so, dass du
sagst, hier, ich stelle
ein Gigabyte oder ein Terabyte
auf meiner Platte zur Verfügung für andere.
Das kriegst du dann als Currency raus.
Wir haben irgendwie so ein Currency-System.
und dann wird da dein Zeugs im Wert von dem, was du selber zur Verfügung stellst,
im Netzwerk verteilt.
Wozu brauche ich diesen Wert?
Kann ich mit Daten nur kaufen?
Du kannst auch, glaube ich, Geld reinstecken.
Aber das Konzept bei denen ist, dass dir Teile des Netzes,
also du ownst, glaube ich, eine bestimmte Kapazität an Speicher im Netzwerk
und
dann werden deine Daten
kryptografisch sicher
und geschartet
im
Matesafe-Netzwerk verteilt.
Und dann ist es quasi wie
PipePipe, es ist überall.
Ah, und keine Box.
There's no Box.
And it's instantly available because it's so fast.
Krass.
Aber ich meine,
ist das eine Art,
ich habe einen Client und
eine bestimmte Menge an Festplattenspeicher bereit für das Netzwerk,
um Daten drauf zu speichern. Also die Prämisse ist erstmal,
stell dir vor, es ist wie
OwnCloud oder Dropbox, bloß, dass du
nicht einen Server hast, sondern dass es sich gleichmäßig
über alle Teilnehmer verteilt.
OwnCloud hat ja auch so ein Federated-Protokoll-Seiten.
Das ist was anderes.
Da kannst du sagen, da kannst du quasi
Ordner von anderen bei dir mounten.
Achso, das ist nicht das Gleiche.
Und Matesafe macht das halt
mehr oder weniger automatisch verteilt über das
Netzwerk und... Genau.
In Matesafe versucht deine Daten so gut wie möglich im Netzwerk breitzuschmieren,
dass ja nichts passieren kann.
Okay, aber damit ich das machen darf, wird das irgendwie durch diese Currency verwaltet,
damit es nicht unfair genutzt wird von irgendeinem.
Genau, also ich hatte die Ehre auf dem Kongress,
einen Mitarbeiter von Matesafe kennenzulernen,
der hätte mir das mal 10 Minuten erklärt.
Aber das wäre auch sowas, was man eigentlich nochmal ausbreiten könnte.
Okay, ich weiß nicht viel über Matesafe.
Ich weiß bloß, dass ich den Namen komisch finde und das doch in Rust implementiert ist, oder?
Von dem Namen wollen sie weg.
Deswegen heißt es Safe Network,
was natürlich ein
unbeschwerter Name ist.
Ein bisschen generisch, aber
dieser Made-Teil fällt raus.
Gibt es eine andere Bedeutung des Wortes Made,
die mir einfach nicht geläufig sind?
Made-Safe heißt, es ist ja ein Begriff aus der
Kryptowissenschaft, du möchtest halt,
selbst wenn bei dir
die Putzfrau reinkommt und überall rankommt,
während du nicht da bist.
Ah, daher kommt das, okay.
Es ist selbst von deiner Made-Safe.
Komischer Name. Ich mag ihn trotzdem nicht.
Nee, den versteht doch keiner, deswegen
ist er, glaube ich, davon auch weggegangen.
Ich weiß noch, wo ein gemeinsamer Freund von uns,
Sebastian, aus Japan
zurückkam mit ein paar Fotos
und Erfahrungsberichten aus so einem Maid-Café.
Maid-Café?
Ja, diese komischen Cafés.
Ich will jetzt niemandem hier auf die Füße treten,
aber gefühlt ist das halt, was catert
an Leute mit interessanten
Tendenzen, oder was heißt interessant,
mit halt Maid-Fetischen.
Ist ja völlig okay, aber
Ich finde, diese Cafés sind da ein bisschen weird.
Wenn man so guckt, was es in Japan alles gibt.
Aber vielleicht ist es auch einfach nach.
Man hört das auf Japan.
Das ist meine persönliche Meinung dazu.
War dieses komische Klo-Café, war das in China oder in Japan?
Ein Klo-Café, das klingt wieder spannend.
Da sitzt du überall auf Toilettenschüsseln.
Und deine Kaffeetassen sehen auch aus wie Toilettentütteln.
Aber ich soll die doch bitte nicht benutzen, während ich dort bin, oder?
Nein, du sollst da nicht.
Aber es sieht halt alles aus wie Bad.
Achso, das ist wirklich bloß
Du trinkst aus Pötten, die aussehen
wie Kloschüsseln
Es ist nicht, wenn da ganz viel brauner Kaffee drin ist
Ich finde das
schön, wie unsere allererste Podcast-Folge
in so saubere Chapters schon
zu unterteilen ist
die hier schön von einem zum anderen
gehen, ich freue mich, das nachher zusammen zu
Also, wir müssen dazu sagen
wir haben uns ja
null vorbereitet, wir nehmen uns schon lange vor
eigentlich müssen wir mal einen Podcast aufnehmen, weil wir wissen
weder wie es heißen soll noch was das nicht mehr so gerade die erste folge auf wir wollten mal eine
nullrunde machen das ist die unsere motivation wir wollten mal eine erste folge aufnehmen und
einfach mal ein bisschen quatschen um zu sehen wie gut es funktioniert und das alles als nullrunde
hochzuladen aber es wird natürlich ein podcast was gibt es denn sonst für podcast naja ist
ich will da keine musik zwischendrin ein hörst du hörst du mich nicht direkt ich versuche es immer
wieder, aber die sind mir so lang, die Folgen.
Ich komme da einfach,
ich fange jede Folge mal an
und dann nach einer halben Stunde, oh nee,
ich will eigentlich nicht die nächsten
dreieinhalb Stunden immer noch diesen Podcast hören.
Ich will eigentlich noch ein paar andere. Du hast Podcast immer am Stück, ne?
Ich höre Podcast meist am Stück.
Also nicht, also solange ich, also was heißt
am Stück, ich höre Podcast, wenn ich zur Bahn
laufe, in die Straßenbahn einsteige
und wenn ich zu Hause ankomme, mache ich es aus. Und wenn ich mit in der Folge bin,
dann höre ich die halt das nächste Mal weiter. Genau.
Also so eine
methodische Korrektfolge, die kann ich schon drei, vier Tage lang.
Ja, das ist eben das Problem. Da habe ich das Gefühl, ich komme nicht
weiter und mein Backlog wächst in der Zeit halt auch an.
Und ich höre halt von dem Podcast, die ich höre,
meistens wirklich alle Folgen.
Gut, okay. Also es gibt ein paar, da höre ich
immer mal rein. Ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel mal wieder
angefangen mit 99% Invisible.
Hast du ein schöner Podcast? Ja.
Wovon ich tatsächlich keine Folge verpassen möchte, ist
Radiolab. Niemals. Never.
Radiolab wird komplett durchgehört.
Also wenn ihr Radiolab noch nicht kennt, Radiolab
ist ein Podcast. Also ich habe schon
Tränen in den Augen gehabt bei meinen Folgen.
Absolut großartig.
Das kann ich bezeugen. Also ich war nicht dabei, aber mir ging es ähnlich.
Radio Lab ist fantastisch.
Generell gibt es viele großartige Podcasts von NPR.
Nicht alle gehen so ein bisschen auf so eine emotionale Ebene.
Das Storytelling ist einfach gut.
Ja, das haben sie wirklich drauf.
Ich meine, sie sind ein klassischer Radiosender, die haben eine Ahnung, was das angeht.
Aber ich meine, sie gehen wirklich auf viele...
Planet Money höre ich auch jede Folge.
Das hat mich gar nicht so...
Worum geht es da?
Alles, was irgendwo auch im Fernsten mit Geld zu tun hat.
Jetzt sollte ich damit mal anfangen.
Es ist spannend, um viel zu lernen.
Und Sie ziehen auch oftmals einfach nur Reruns von alten Folgen durch.
Gerade heute, als ich auf dem Weg hierher war,
beziehungsweise nicht hierher, aber fast auf dem Weg hierher,
habe ich eine Money-Folge gehört, wo es über den Dow Jones ging.
Und ich persönlich wusste nicht viel über den Dow Jones.
Ich wusste, der existiert und der ist irgendein Index für so wie Dingens.
Wie heißt der bei uns?
Der Äquivalent dazu?
Der DAX.
Der DAX, genau.
Ich wusste aber nicht, wie der berechnet wird.
Und das finde ich jetzt auch nicht so spannend.
Wenn ich zu Hause bin,
dann würde ich mich niemals durchlesen, wie würde der Dow Jones eigentlich berechnen.
Aber die Folge fing an mit, wir bei Planet Money
hassen übrigens den Dow Jones,
weil der absolut scheiße ist und absolut nichts aussagt.
Aber trotzdem bin ich in den Medien immer so gehypt.
Und hier, das ist übrigens der Grund,
warum wir den Kacker finden.
Der Grund, kurz abgerissen, ist, dass da nur 30
arbiträr ausgewählte Firmen drin liegen.
Nicht heutzutage.
Das sind die 30 größten?
Ne, also es waren mal die 30. Das sind alte Firmen.
Google findest du da nicht, Facebook findest du da nicht.
Also Firmen, die moderner sind, findest du da nicht.
Und das Beschissenste daran,
weil ich eigentlich...
Ich denke, das ist so eine Art Bundesliga,
wo du irgendwie rein und raus fällst,
je nachdem, wie relevant du bist.
Sofern ich das heute verstanden habe,
sind die 30 einfach festgelegt.
Und solange die 30 noch existieren,
bleiben es auch diese 30.
Das ist bescheuert.
Und das noch bescheuere daran ist,
dass die nicht deinen eigentlichen Firmenwert nehmen,
sondern den Wert,
den eine Aktie hoch oder runter fährt.
Und wenn du halt mehr Aktien hast,
die weniger hoch und runter fahren,
im Wert, nicht prozentual,
sondern im Wert,
im tatsächlich einen Wert,
wenn du 10 Aktien hast,
du hast
Beispiel in Planet Money, ich habe eine Firma
100 Dollar wert ist die Firma
hat 100 Aktien, jeweils 1 Dollar
und ich habe eine andere Firma, die ist 100 Dollar wert
und hat 2 Aktien, jeweils 50 Dollar
und wenn beide 10%
draufhauen, dann haut die eine Firma
auf jeder Aktie 10 Cent drauf
und die andere auf jeder Aktie 5 Dollar
und die mit 5 Dollar ist halt um ein vielfaches Mehrwert
als die andere Aktie und deshalb ist die Firma
auch um ein vielfaches Mehrwert, was totaler Quatsch ist
die sind beide auf 110 Dollar
an dem Punkt
So rechnet der Dow Jones eben.
Das sagt einfach überhaupt nichts aus.
Und warum behält man daran fest?
Weil man dann geschönt die
Wirtschaftsleile der USA darstellen kann?
Geschönt in dem Sinne, dass man einfach
in einem historischen Kontext packen kann.
Weil der Dow Jones halt seit 1800 irgendwann
existiert. Und die Firmen, die da drin sind,
gab es alle damals schon und die gibt es heute immer noch?
Das kann ich mir ehrlich gesagt, in dem Moment, wo du es sagst,
auch nicht ganz vorstellen. Vielleicht wechseln die
tatsächlich irgendwann mal, aber du findest,
wie auf Planet Money, wo du wie gesagt hast,
die modernen Firmen keine Rolle spielen.
deshalb sagt es halt echt wenig aus.
Die Berechnung ist Schwachsinn und das
Firmenspektrum ist Schwachsinn. Nur 30 Firmen
sagt halt auch wenig aus. Es gibt ja diesen
SPN 500 und den 1000.
Diese Indexindizes, die
bedeuten mehr Firmen reinnehmen und die bedeuten
sinnvoller Rechnen. Einfach nur auf dem
gesamten Market Cap eben und nicht auf einzelner
Aktienbasis.
Ein Share ist eine Aktie, oder?
Wir bewegen uns gerade.
Ich glaube,
das ist ein Zeichen dafür, dass wir dieses Thema
hier jetzt auch canceln soll.
Okay, also man kann also,
wir sind in der Sparte von Podcast-Empfehlung,
Planet Money, kann man noch was lernen.
Es geht auch meistens oft um andere Dinge,
meistens um Firmen, Geld, Haushalt
im privaten Bereich. Also alles, was
im Entferntesten damit zu tun hat und das ist echt spannend.
Ist das auf Europa und Deutschland
übertragbar, was man da lernt? Übertragbar sicherlich,
bezogen im Normalfall nicht.
Also Bankensystem findest du auch mal
internationalere Dinge. Ich glaube,
auf Island war auch schon mal, beziehungsweise
Kolumbien war eine spannende Folge. Die war schon ein paar Monate her,
wie das Bankensystem bei denen komplett gegen die Wand fährt
und dann alles kaputt geht.
Das hat sich auch überhaupt nicht geändert seitdem.
Aber es sind schon ein bisschen globaler angesiedelt,
aber meistens ist es auf die USA bezogen,
beispielhaft.
Aber es ist ein guter Podcast.
Und es sind 20 Minuten Folgen,
die hörst du sehr schnell durch.
Wenn dein Podcast-Player ein bisschen schneller
als einfache Geschwindigkeit spielt.
Das wäre noch wichtig,
dass man irgendwie pro Podcast, pro Feed
eine extra Geschwindigkeit abspielen kann.
Ich bin ja nicht so ein Speed-Hörer wie du.
Ich kann mir das nicht auf doppelte Geschwindigkeit anhören.
Ich habe mir das vorhin mausbrüht, aber das ist irgendwie zu schnell.
Bitte?
Aber bei manchen Podcasts
tatsächlich hat man eine Zeit lang
hier von Twit
Security Now gehört.
This Week in Tech.
Security Now mit Steve Gibson gehört.
Aber zum einen ist da,
ist bei den ganzen Twit Podcasts oder
Netcasts, wir wollten den Begriff Podcast
nicht verwenden, weil der ja von Apple geprägt ist.
Das kommt ja von iPod.
Echt?
Ja, deswegen heißt das Netcasts.
von People you trust. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass der Podteil
von Podcasts von iPod kommt.
Das sind Casts,
die du dir direkt auf deinen Pod ziehst.
Ha, hab ich nicht drüber nachgedacht.
Also, wo RSS herkommt, weiß ich,
aber ich hab nie die Verkürzung im Hirn
die hinterfragt, wo der Name Podcast herkommt.
Spannend.
Von iPod. Wenn du es auf einem großen Gerät
hörst, wäre es eigentlich ein Padcast
oder ein Droidcast.
Deswegen haben die gesagt, nee, das ist uns zu
produktspezifisch. Wir nennen das jetzt Netcast.
Die haben sich damit aber leider nie durchgesetzt.
Aber zumindest bei denen ist überall Werbung drin.
Da kommt am Anfang Werbung und zwischendurch Werbung,
wobei die ganzen Ami-Podcasts sind ja eh mit Werbung durchsetzt.
Übrigens, wir müssen hier mal ganz kurz eine Unterbrechung machen.
Unsere heutige Folge ist übrigens gesponsert von...
Von Tolle Mate.
Ob sie es wollen oder nicht.
Bitteschön, wir trinken gerade leckere Mate aus...
Original aus der Dresdner Neustadt.
Nicht mehr ganz, aber...
Immerhin hat sie dort angefangen.
Und es sind tolle Leute mit tollen Firmenkonzepten.
Und wir mögen die sehr.
Schönen Gruß an Eduard und Anne.
Ja, ich freue mich, euch mal wieder zu sehen im ASCII.
So hetzt es die Werbung.
Jetzt war der Werbung.
Ja, und
bei den ganzen Army-Podcasts hast du dann zwischendurch
Werbung für Casper und für Harrys
und für diesen ganzen Scheiß, den du bestellen kannst.
Und da möchte ich gerne echt irgendwie mal schneller
abspielen. Mal davon abgesehen, dass Steven Gibson übelst
langsam redet und dann redet. Das sind so Sachen,
das ist so ein Feature, was du von
Podcast zu Podcast. Wenn es halt die saubere
Kapitelmarken gibt, dann kann man die Werbung
überspringen. Also wenn du das ATP macht, das mit den Kapitelmarken
direkt auf die Werbung. Ja, ich glaube, Leute, die Kapitelmarken
machen und Werbung machen, die machen das nicht so, dass du
schön sauber die Werbung überspringst. Ich kann es verstehen,
wenn sie es nicht tun, aber ich finde es auch
nett für den Hörer, wenn sie es tun.
Die Podcasts haben oft dieselbe Werbung.
Ich weiß nicht, wie oft ich Casper-Werbung schon gehört habe.
Ich kenne Casper, ich kenne
Matratzen, ich weiß, dass es die jetzt gibt.
Mittlerweile haben die sogar Werbung im
deutschen Fernsehen, die muss gar nicht jetzt im deutschen Markt existieren.
Da gibt es sogar so eine Abklatschfirma,
die, was ist eine Abklatschfirma?
Ich weiß nicht, es ist unfair, ob ich die runterrede.
Ich habe auch vergessen, wie die heißen.
Es gibt eine Firma, die verkauft Matratzen in der exakt derselben Optik,
mit exakt derselben Idee dahinter.
Haben leicht vor Casper im deutschen Markt gestartet.
Wie gesagt, keine Ahnung, wie die heißen.
Ich würde auch keine Schleichwerbung hier machen.
Wegen Casper, ja, sonst wie häufig anscheinend.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob Casper gut ist.
Ich glaube es nicht.
Ich würde sie tatsächlich gerne mal probieren.
Aber ich würde mir niemals so eine gigantische Matratze
in so einem kleinen, laut Werbung,
einen gigantischen Paket bestellen.
In der Höhe kriegst du sie tatsächlich von Fahrradfahrern ausgeliefert.
wie bestellst du kriegst eine halbe Stunde später
das ist das Konzept also das ist das
die sind irgendwie vakuum verpackt
und die sind ganz klein und dann packst du die aus
ganz klein hast du mal gesehen denn die Kiste ist
ein Quadratmeter Grundriss und anderthalb
Meter hoch also ganz klein
also das ist klein für eine Matratze
aber ganz klein ist das jetzt nicht
aber ich glaube das ist Teil des Konzepts weil du darfst sie ja irgendwie
100 Tage ausprobieren und dann darfst du sie
aber die musst du erstmal so klein
wieder zusammen kriegen
ich hoffe mal also
ich habe es nicht ausprobiert aber wenn die
Refund-Policy von denen ist, ja, du kannst sie gerne probieren,
aber wenn du sie zurückschickst, musst du sie uns zurückschicken.
Dann ist das ein Quatsch.
Wahrscheinlich wird es auch nicht so sein,
ich würde gerne zurückschicken, wann kommt ihr sie abholen?
Ich glaube, der Hintergrund
von dieser 100-Tage-Test-Policy ist einfach, dass
die bequemische Schleppkeit der Leute ausnutzen, die sagen,
ach, ich habe es jetzt eher mal hier liegen.
Es kommt halt erst mal
unglaublich dem Kunden entgegen, wenn du sagst,
du verkaufst hier und du kannst es
100 oder 200 Tage, wie lange es auch immer ist, ausprobieren.
Das ist mehr als ein halbes Jahr
oder ein Dritteljahr, ein zweitritteljahr,
wie auch immer. Und dann kannst du dir
dich lange drauflegen und dich dran gewöhnen.
Und vielleicht ist ja wirklich dein Ding und dann scheiß drauf.
Du hast ja eh schon bezahlt.
Es ist ja nicht so, als ob du dir die erste Nacht der Testzeit bezahlst.
Du bezahlst ja schon beim Kauf.
Ich habe ja eine ganze Zeit lang
im Studentenwohnheim gewohnt.
Ich auch, ja.
In so einem kleinen möblierten Zimmer,
wo alles vom Studentenwohnheim vorgegeben ist.
Ich brauchte meine Matratze, die war hart und geil.
Da hast du eine Matratze vorgegeben.
Und ich hatte
den Zeitraum, den ich da gewohnt habe,
weil ich sehr viele unterschiedliche Mitbewohner und zweimal auch.
Was für eine, wie groß war deine WG dort?
Das waren acht Leute.
Acht Leute?
Mit welchem Wohleibs hast du gewohnt?
Das sage ich jetzt hier nicht.
Ich kenne gar keine achter WGs.
Ich habe eine alleine in meinem ersten Aparten gehabt.
Ja, acht mal elf Quadratmeter und vier Bäder und eine riesengroße Küche.
Okay.
Also die Küche war vielleicht, war dann 25 bis 30 Quadratmeter groß.
Das war schon anständig.
Aber, nee, war nicht 30, die war 25 Quadratmeter groß.
Aber egal, zumindest ich hatte zweimal unabhängig voneinander eine südkoreanische Mitbewohnerin,
klavier studiert hat und die hatten beide vorher woanders gewohnt wo sie ihr
eigenes zeug hatten und haben dann ganz viel möbel und zeugs mitgebracht die
die eine hatte ganz viel möbel und zeug mitgebracht hat irgendwie dass ich in
diesem elf quadratmeter zimmer hatte den kühlschrank stehen und reis koche und
natürlich noch noch extra kleiderschrank und dass die andere hatte nicht so viel
zeug aber die hat sich auch mal gedacht diese matratze ist mir nicht bequem
genug ich kaufe mir jetzt meine eigene matratze
Und dann hat sie die Matratze rausgenommen,
hat die eigene Matratze da draufgelegt
und dann
haben wir selber irgendwie aufgeklärt,
dass die Matratze, die da drin war, die kannst du halt nicht
einfach wegschmeißen, die gehört ja irgendwie dem Studentenwohnheim
und der Hausmeister wollte die auch nicht
irgendwo zwischenlagern.
Einlagern ist halt schwierig.
Dann hat sie dann quasi
das nächste halbe Jahr, das sie da noch gewohnt hat,
diese zwei Matratzen in ihrem Zimmer
gehabt, was ja so schön klein ist.
Ich glaube, die hat die einfach übereinandergelegt.
Die neue einfach drauf.
Ein bisschen höher geschlossene Prinzessin auf der Erde.
Das waren so 30 Zentimeter.
Okay, das ist schon...
Da schlägt schon ein gutes Stück höher plötzlich.
Das muss komisch sein.
Das war auch komisch, Autofant.
Ich weiß noch, wie sie mir plötzlich gefragt hat,
kannst du mir mal helfen hier,
die Matratze aus meinem Zimmer zu schleppen?
Wohin?
Ich habe meine Matratze geliebt.
Ich habe mir eine Matratze geliebt.
Die ist toll.
Ich würde gar nicht drüber nachdenken,
wie viele Leute da vor mir schon drauf geschlafen haben.
Nee, das passt auch nicht.
Du stehst ja nicht auf der Matratze direkt.
Der Gedanke ist immer irgendwo da,
aber die Matratze, auf der ich schlafe aktuell,
auf der schlafen auch Menschen schon seit Jahren.
Und diese Menschen sind hauptsächlich eine Teilgruppe von mir.
Ich fand diese Vorstellung witzig,
in so einem Hochhaus zu wohnen,
in einem von zehn Stockwerken,
in einem von acht Zimmern auf deinem Flur,
die alle das gleiche Layout haben,
oder spiegelverkehrt,
Und du liegst dann so abends im Bett und du weißt genau,
über mir liegen jetzt genau der
gleichen Anordnung, vielleicht manchmal mit dem Kopf
in Richtung 10 Leute und unter mir
nochmal 3 oder sowas.
Und dann
wie so eine Bienenwabe.
Eine Perlenschnur nach oben durch.
Alle so im Bett.
Nachts ist der Moment, wo sich die Leute an demselben
wenigen Quadratmeter
einfinden in ihrer Wohnung,
wo die Betten stehen. Vor allem im
Wohnheim sind die Betten zumindest schon mal
an der Stelle, wo sie von Haus aus stehen.
Da haben die Leute die Zimmer auch nicht komplett selbst eingerichtet.
Es geht eigentlich nur um solche Wohnheimen, die auch wie vorher eingerichtet sind.
Und auch nur an denen, wo du wirklich so ein Mini-Zimmer hast, wo du nicht viel machen kannst.
Also es gibt ja Wohnheimen, wo die Zimmer auch sich unterscheiden.
Ja klar.
Und wo du auch ein bisschen Variation hast.
Aber das war wirklich wie so eine, ich glaube Leute, die wissen aus welcher Stadt wir kommen.
Die wissen auch mittlerweile...
Haben wir Dresden schon erwähnt?
Haben wir Dresden erwähnt?
Wir haben Kolle-Mat erwähnt.
Dresden Neustadt.
Ah, kennst du, pass auf Werbung, kennst du Dresden, hat Durst?
Ja, also nur von
deiner Erzählung gestern, verdammt.
Genau, also es gibt auch so eine Bude, die wollten
uns im ASCII, da kam einer rein.
Also das ASCII ist übrigens ein studentisches Café
in der Fakultät Informatik der TU Dresden,
in dem wir beide als Mitglieder tätig sind.
Wir wollten eigentlich die Folge
im ASCII aufnehmen, oder die Folgen
im ASCII aufnehmen, wir überlegen
nochmal noch, ob das ASCII-Cast nennt.
Das wäre auch eine Idee. Warum eigentlich nicht?
Oft einmal über das ASCII reden. Wir haben bis jetzt natürlich
nicht über das ASCII gesprochen. Das ist auch ein bisschen komisch, wo wir jetzt beide
so ein bisschen raus sind aus dem ASCII mittlerweile.
Ja, aber es ist ja nicht so, ob wir nicht ASCII-affin sind
und oft genug uns mit dem ASCII auseinandersetzen.
Oder wir nehmen, ich meine, wir besitzen ja neben ASCII Dresden
auch noch Unicode und UTF-8 Dresden.
Besitzen wir schon Emoji Dresden?
Als Domain meinst du?
Wir müssen eigentlich noch eine Emoji,
und dann machen wir den ganzen Titel von der Seite,
machen wir alles mit Emojis.
Nice.
Ich habe gestern Matrix geguckt mit Leuten.
Einfach auf bloß, weil wir irgendwie auf...
Was war denn das?
ich saß mit denen da und irgendjemand sagt es kommt ein neues Nokia raus
und ich sage bei Matrix haben sie diese geilen Aufklappen
Nokias
komm lass uns nochmal Matrix gucken
und dann waren wir irgendwann mittendrin und das war ja
der Film ist von 1999
und du siehst diese eulen
diese eulen
CAT-Monitor
und die hässlichen weißen Keyboards
und die
Zip-Discs auf denen er seine Daten da weitergibt
oder was es ist
und dann denkst du dir, ach ja das war das damals
und dann siehst du irgendwann diese ganzen Bildschirme
wo der asiatische Text durchläuft.
Das sind einfach alle möglichen Sonderzeichen,
die sie gefunden haben in den Zeichensätzen.
War das nicht einfach großteils asiatisch?
Ich würde jetzt nichts drauf schwören.
Es läuft da grüner Text durch,
weil man halt Ende der 90er gedacht hat,
muss das aussehen.
Das schaut doch auch,
die Lebensmittel halt alles wahren Hackers aus.
Ich denke mir so in dem Moment,
wenn der Film heute gedreht worden wäre,
würden da Emotis durchlaufen.
Wirklich?
Kennst du das Wort?
Sobald ich das verstanden habe, ist das der Code,
der unsere Welt widerspiegelt,
den du live siehst auf diesem Bildschirm.
Aus irgendeinem Grund fließt der halt von oben
nach unten durch. Der weiß Asiatisches.
Der fließt doch nicht deshalb von oben
nach unten, weil es Asiatisch ist, sondern einfach nur, weil es cool ausschaut,
oder? Das waren doch keine asiatischen Zeichen
explizit, sondern einfach alles mögliche an Sonderzeichen
außer typisches Ausrufseite-Fragezeichen-Kram
findest du halt nicht, aber
nicht überhaupt nicht. Aber selbst wenn,
der fließt doch nicht deshalb von oben nach unten durch.
Egal, selbst wenn,
selbst wenn
die Idee dahinter war ja, das ist der Code,
der die Welt darstellt, der diese
Fake-Welt und unsere Matrix halt eben
darstellt. Die wäre
in Emojis geschrieben.
Jetzt auch Emoji-Code.
Ja, das ist auch toll, aber das ist
Emoji-Code ist halt wunderschön.
Also zumindest müsste
mal so ein Emoji drin vorkommen.
Klappt Emoji-Code eigentlich wunderbar mit den
Emoji-Feinheiten, die wir gestern entdeckt haben,
dass du einfach zum Beispiel ein Mann-Emoji, ein Frau-Emoji
und ein Kind-Emoji zusammen addieren kannst für ein
Familien-Emoji oder ein Mann-Emoji
Herz-Emoji Mann-Emoji
Ach Gott, schwer zu sagen. Mann-Emoji
Herz-Emoji, Mann-Emoji ist ein schwules Paar,
Frau-Emoji Herz-Emoji
Fraue-Emoji ist ein lesbisches Paar und dass diese halt
Emojiz direkt zusammengeführt werden. Kann Emoji-Code
das? Kann man damit irgendwas cooles machen?
Du könntest damit bestimmt irgendwie algebraische
Datentypen abbilden. Nice.
Da musst du halt, Emoji
sind halt da nicht so klar
durchdefinden. Du hast ja nur diese paar
Compound-Emojis, wenn die überhaupt so zu beschreiben sind.
Man müsste sich mal die ganzen
mathematischen Kombinationen, die sich daraus bilden
lassen. Wahrscheinlich so ekelhaft zusammengehackt.
Das sieht ja alles in
Unicorn irgendwo.
Quasi gibt es noch bestimmte
Emojis, die Modifikatoren von anderen Emojis
sind. Zum Beispiel das Hautfarbe-Emoji.
Damit kannst du ja von jeder
Figur die Hautfarbe ändern. Von den
Figuren, die eine Hautfarbe haben. Also für die
klassischen gelben Smilies kannst du das nicht.
Nee, aber für eine Hand zum Beispiel.
Mann, Frau, Kim, Baby. Feuerwehrmann,
Tänzer. Weihnachtsmann.
Der Weihnachtsmann sieht so komisch aus.
Aber nur der Emoji One Weihnachtsmann.
Aber der Apple Emoji Weihnachtsmann
gefällt mir auch nicht.
Dieser Satz von mir jetzt drauf war.
Du hast gesagt, der Weihnachtsmann sieht creepy aus.
Ich sag's nochmal für den Kontext.
Der Emoji One sieht echt super creepy aus.
Der sieht aus, als ob er gerade sagt.
Buh!
So weit aufgerissenen blauen Augen.
Diese blauen Augen sind echt ein bisschen creepy.
Also die sind halt wirklich bloß blaue Kreise.
Da ist kein Auge drumherum.
Das sind einfach nur blaue Kreise.
Nee, ganz ehrlich, Emoji Code?
Nee.
Ich fand's halt geil, dass du diese...
Ich weiß nicht mehr viel von Emoji-Code.
Einfach nur hier auf the top of my head.
Einfach nur so Dinge wie, du hast dieses Paketsymbol,
um ein Package zu deklarieren.
Es ist so schön sauber spezifiziert.
Emoji hat halt nicht viele Modifikatoren,
außer diesen Hautfarbe-Dingen eingebaut.
Und die klappen halt nur auf die Hälfte der Emojis.
Man könnte noch...
Es gibt ja Personen.
Es gibt Mann, Frau, Mann mit blonden Haaren, Kind,
kleines Mädchen, kleiner Junge, Baby.
die könntest du jetzt noch mit den einzelnen
Smilies kombinieren,
dass du den Gesichtsausdruck austauscht.
Das musst du halt custom bauen.
Das kann Unicode halt nicht von Hause aus.
Das ist halt nicht im Standard definiert.
Ja, aber dann kannst du ein Texteditor halt auch nicht anzeigen.
Du könntest Box
mit Hund kombinieren.
Dann hast du eine
Box voller Poppies.
Aber da musst du halt ein Custom Editor schreiben,
der das auch so schön anzeigen kann.
Das ist halt das Problem, woran das scheitert.
Emojis sind halt Text.
Und das ist so kaputt.
Es ist cool, es ist unglaublich mächtig.
Ein Schind, so ein Smiley-Standard.
Die Forensoftware der 90er Jahre, wo du halt
diese animierten, breiten
BB-Code. Oh, BB-Code war geil.
Also ich bin
tierisch froh, dass es heutzutage markt.
Aber
stell dir mal was anderes vor.
Stell dir mal vor, die Computer,
die Unix-Systeme,
die wir heutzutage benutzen werden,
wären nicht als erstes von den Amerikanern
entwickelt worden oder in Europa
von den Amerikanern entwickelt worden,
sondern stell dir vor, wir wären 20 Jahre
hinterher und die Chinesen hätten die ersten Computer
gebaut und auf der Welt verbreitet.
Du meinst, es wäre einfach ein anderes Default-Char-Set
existiert, was auch
kein Rückblick auf unsere Zeichen genommen hätte?
Jeder, der eine Programmiersprache lernt, muss Englisch
lernen. Da sind englische Begriffe fest.
Das stimmt nicht ganz.
Jeder, der eine populäre Programmiersprache lernen möchte, ja.
Aber stell dir mal vor, einfach die
verbreitetsten systemnahen Sprachen,
das C von heute,
würde auf chinesischen Zeichen basieren.
Das wäre interessant.
Das würde quasi,
hätte das der Chinesen
in der westlichen Welt nicht durchgesetzt, glaube ich.
Weil, ich meine...
Und selbst die Sprachen, heutzutage ist es so,
selbst die Sprachen...
Die englische Teile der Welt ist nicht so weltoffen
gegenüber anderen Dingen, habe ich das Gefühl.
Ja, selbst die Sprachen, die in Japan entwickelt werden,
wie Ruby, benutzen englische Keywords.
Dann würde ich ja mal
die Ursprungshistory von Ruby
mit BATS, doch heißt er,
besprechen. Ich meine, der hat sicherlich
die Wahl gehabt. Das war
ChangeLog Nummer 200?
Er war vor kurzem, aber da haben sie
darüber nicht gesprochen. Zumindest über diese Entscheidung
für, ich baue eine englische Sprache oder ich baue eine japanische Sprache.
Er hat gemeint, er hat sich sehr...
Doch, es gibt irgendeine deutsche und die ist scheiße,
die ist schrott, die ist esoterisch.
Blankalkül oder sowas?
Darüber habe ich nicht mehr gedacht.
Also was gibt es auch noch?
Man müsste mal Programmiersprachen.
Man müsste mal Blanca,
ganz ehrlich, fürchterlich.
Ich bin froh, dass es heutzutage wieder neue
Programmiersprachen gibt und dass man nicht alles mit C++ machen muss.
Wir haben gerade nicht erwähnt,
dass du voll der Rust-Fanboy bist.
Ach stimmt, gar nicht.
Als sie das Rächeln auf deinem Gesicht
geben, kommt jetzt gar nicht richtig rüber
in dem Podcast.
Wir sind ja vorher kurz
darauf eingegangen, dass wir beide sehr gerne
uns mit diversen Sprachen auseinandersetzen.
Meine Lieblingssprache der letzten
Wochen, sage ich schon, Monate,
Jahre ist eigentlich Swift, bei dir ist es
Rust. Ich würde fast sagen,
wir hängen da beide jetzt so lange,
ähnlich lange aktuell drin in der
Entwicklung der Sprachen,
beziehungsweise setzen uns damit auseinander,
schreiben darin sehr viel Code. Man kann sich auch super
austauschen, weil die Sprachen so verwandt sind. Ja, die teilen
sich echt viel. Also Swift und Rust sind beides wunderbare
Sprachen. Ich fasse jetzt auch in den letzten
Tagen, fast Wochen,
endlich mal wieder mehr Rust an
und verfind mich daran wieder. Aber es ist auch
unglaublich simpel, weil ich einfach sehr viel mit Swift teile.
Die Grundprinzipien sind sehr ähnlich. Beide
haben den schönen Default, keine
Non-Werte, schön beide mit
Optional-Stypen, dann hast du noch den
Result-Typen damit eingebaut und damit lässt sich
schon das meiste sauber abbilden, was du
in anderen Sprachen für Probleme hast im Alltag.
Das sind halt alles Features, das ist mir später erst aufgefallen,
sind alles Features aus funktionalen Programmiersprachen.
Oft, ja. Das sind alles Features, die
du hast bei Haskell schon gehabt, du hast es bloß nicht
gemerkt. Das ist deine Maybe-Monade als
Optional-Style-Made-Monade.
Genau, genau.
Ich meine, klar, die Ideen sind da, die Ideen sind ja auch
nichts Sprachspezifisches. Ich meine,
Swift wirft noch ein bisschen Syntaktik-Sugar mit drauf.
In Rust ist das nichts sprachspezifisches.
Es ist einfach nur in der Sprache implementiert
und liegt in der Preload zufällig mit drin.
Der Rest sind beide sauber typisierte Sprachen.
Das ist recht schön.
Rust hat einen fantastischen Compiler mit fantastischen Fehlermeldungen.
Sowas Geiles habe ich sonst noch nicht gesehen.
Swift hat einen sehr beta-sich anfühlenden Compiler,
der oft segfaultet.
Swift ist halt noch nicht gebootstrapped.
Das geht halt aktuell auch nicht.
Das ist halt das Problem.
Swift kann halt nicht nativ C++-Code callen.
Und der Compiler ist komplett in C++ geschrieben.
Und bevor du LLVM nicht neu schreibst
oder neu implementierst,
da müssen sie halt
sehr viel Arbeit reinstecken, um es zu bootstrippen.
Und daran scheitert es aktuell komplett.
Ist das so?
Ich glaube, das ist nicht unbedingt notwendig.
Das ist zumindest Chris Leitners Argumentation.
Ich habe mich persönlich
nachgedacht, was man für Arbeit reinstecken müsste, um es zu bootstrippen.
Swift C ist
in C++ geschrieben.
Und Rust C ist in Rust geschrieben.
Beide bauen sie auf LLVM auf.
beide bauen sie auf LLVM auf und
Bindings nach, ich weiß gar nicht,
wie der Rust-Compiler das macht.
Das wäre auch mal eine interessante Sache.
Willst du mal deinen Bullshit schon reinpacken?
Zumindest mit der Thematik mal auch einander setzen, weil das würde mich auch interessieren.
Wie, das ist gar nicht das.
Wie
Rust
LLVM
anschließt.
Interessant. Ich weiß es nicht.
Keine Ahnung. Aber LVM
labelt ja noch
diverse andere Sprachen, die es auch aufbauen,
coole neue Dinge wie Crystal zum Beispiel.
Ist ja auch LV Empowered, ist auch
self-hosted und ist auch
eine wunderschöne Sprache. Aber Crystal,
ist das noch so nah an Ruby, wie es
sein wollte von Anfang an oder sind die schon
dolle davon? Also sie wollten nie
Kompatibilität mit Ruby Code haben. Aber sie wollten
sehr wie Ruby aussehen. Sie wollten Ruby-esk sein, ja.
Und das sind sie auch immer noch,
sie sehen sich Großteil wie Ruby aus.
Das Einzige, was Crystal halt komplett custom
draufwirft, sind natürlich Typen. Also im Sinne von
Annotyte-Typen und ein
Typ-System, was nicht irgendwie ein bisschen broken ist, wie
in vielen anderen Script-Sprachen.
Und was
Crystal auch noch richtig geil hat, sind algebraische
Datentypen, finde ich.
Da kannst du einfach, du brauchst keine Optionals, wenn du
algebraische Datentypen hast. Ein
Int oder Non ist genauso
viel aus wie ein Optional
in Swift oder Rust, der ein Int oder
ein Non-Case hat, als Inam.
Ja, das sind zwei
unterschiedliche Varianten, algebraische Datentypen.
Es sind zwei unterschiedliche Varianten, aber das ist...
ist das quasi bloß ein Syntax-Sugar
für ein Inam in Swift oder Rust.
Deine Pipe-Schreibweise, die du da hast.
Du meinst, der algebraische Datentyp in Crystal
ist Syntagic-Sugar?
Es gibt ja quasi sowas auch in TypeScript.
Das ist ja kein Syntagic-Sugar.
Ich kann ja den Typen auch sonst wie erweitern.
Du schreibst ja hin,
meine Methode age
gibt mir entweder
un zurück oder non,
wenn ich eine Lady bin
und man mich nach meinem Alter fragt.
Es hat mir nicht so dummeres
eingefallen.
Und da würdest du jetzt bei Crystal schreiben,
der Rückgabetyp
von dieser Methode ist
uintpipenone
oder so? Genau.
Und das
ist ja ein Optional.
Natürlich, in dem Fall ist es ein Optional, aber ich kann ja das beliebig
erweitern. Ich kann ja auch sagen, das ist ein uint oder
ein String. Genau, dementsprechend ist es quasi
ein Inam mit zwei
Cases. Das müssen ja auch nicht zwei sein,
das können ja auch beliebig viele sein.
N-Cases. Natürlich kann ich das
okay, ich könnte das abbilden
in der anderen Sprache mit dem Ina, aber ich würde es nicht erst auf.
Es gibt mir nicht mehr oder weniger
Flexibilität an der Stelle, finde ich.
Also ich persönlich sehe gerade nichts, wo das kommt.
Also der Unterschied ist, dass du
bei der Crystal-Schreibweise
ist es quasi ein bisschen anonym,
weil das ist halt, du schreibst es
halt dort einmal hin und das ist, du kannst
jetzt nicht sagen, das ist jetzt genau das gleiche wie eine andere Methode,
die zufällig den gleichen Rückgabewert
Kombination an Sachen hat. Aber du kannst ja schon
recht viel. Und bei
Swift oder Rust, wo du diese
I-Nams hast, schreibst du quasi einen konkreten
Namen ran. Da hast du quasi zum Beispiel
mein Rückgabewert
kann drei Sorten Error sein.
Und das ist halt ein
Age-Error und der kann fünf
Fälle haben, die sind definiert und entsprechend kann ich sagen,
ich gebe definitiv eine Age. Das ist ja eine Abstraktionsstufe
höher einfach. Das ist einfach benannt.
Okay, das sehe ich ein. Ich habe
die ganzen Cases da unter diesen Age-Error
Error reingehen, Namespace.
Crystal definierst das quasi überall neu.
Oder kann man das...
Ich kann auch alles angeben, das ist kein Problem.
Ah ja, faszinierend.
Was ich cool finde am Crystal Compiler ist, du kannst halt auch in deinem Code durchgehen
und einfach an einer Stelle sagen, hier, ich möchte
diesen Typen unwrappen und sag mal,
wenn das ein String ist, gehen wir bitte in diesen Block rein
und der Compiler entforscht mir auch,
dass in diesem Block dann
das nur vom Typ String ist und nicht mehr
seinen gebraischen Typen hat,
den es vorher hatte. Also wie bei Match.
Genau, genau. Aber dass ich halt wirklich
das vom Compiler mit diese Magic
bekomme, dass halt der Typ
drin sauber ist und nicht
komisch. Ja, das ist genau das Gleiche,
aber ich finde es einfach schön. Das hat mir
sehr gefallen. Das ist super, super sauber.
Und jetzt, bevor ihr, ich meine,
gebrate Datentypen sind ja auch nichts Neues, leben auch
in Haskell schon seit Jahrzehnten.
Das ist keinem auffällt, weil Cambridge Haskell lesen.
Aber tatsächlich, es gibt ja dieses
schöne Haskell-Buch,
was jetzt gerade geschrieben wird, da habe ich mal einen Blick
in den Vorhaben. Auf Haskellbook.com meinst du?
Haskellbook.com, wir machen gerade wieder Werbung.
für Leute wie ich, die...
Ich hab's immer noch nicht geschafft, mir das zu kaufen.
Ich wollte mir das unbedingt mal zulegen und mal durchlesen.
Ja, das nehmen wir uns mal fürs nächste Mal vor, weil ich hab's auch noch auf meiner Wunschliste,
aber ich hab auch keine Zeit, irgendwie gerade was mit der Heske zu machen.
Aber was ich mich gerade bei
Crystal frage, ist
warum nimmt man Crystal...
Also an welchen Stellen entscheidet
man sich für Crystal statt zum Beispiel
M.Ruby? Wenn jetzt die
Aussage ist, es ist quasi
es fühlt sich an wie Ruby, aber es
kompiliert zu nativen Code runter, da könnte ich ja
eigentlich auch MRuby nehmen, oder?
Das große Gegenargument gegen
Crystal aktuell, finde ich, ist, dass
es halt ein komplett eigenes Ecosystem hat
und das ist aktuell einfach, es
existiert, aber es ist quasi nicht
existent, weil es einfach zu
klein noch ist. Und gerade wenn ich irgendein
Projekt in irgendeiner Sprache angehe, dann möchte ich auch, dass
die irgendein Ecosystem hat. Nicht nur, weil ich möchte,
dass die in fünf Jahren noch am Leben sein sollen.
Stimmt, ich habe das Interview auf Changelog mit den
beiden Entwicklern gehört, die halt sich gesagt haben,
Wir haben sowas eigentlich vorher noch nie gemacht und das sind bloß wir beide und ich habe das alleine angefangen.
Das fühlt sich halt immer ein bisschen schwierig an.
Das ist halt wie wenn du Papi Linux benutzt.
Das ist das Derivat von einem Derivat von irgendwas, was fünf Leute entwickeln.
Ich meine, viele Sprachen haben nicht sehr viele Leute dahinter.
Es gibt natürlich die größeren, logisch.
Das ist halt der Grund, warum man sowas wie Go, Swift oder Rust verwenden möchte.
Weil da weißt du, dass da Leute dahinter stehen.
Ja, aber du weißt zumindest, dass da Leute, dass da eine große Menge und große Player dahinter stehen und dass da irgendwie ein Investment da ist.
Und du kannst sagen, die Standard-Library wird gut kuratiert sein, der Compiler-Bugs werden gut gemanaget werden, die Dokumentation wird ganz gut sein.
Das ist halt was, was so kleine Projekte braucht.
Ja, und das nutzen halt schon viele Leute, die halt irgendwo ein Investor Interesse dran haben, dass es auch existent bleibt und dabei sie es eben in dem Code nutzen.
Ich meine, ich habe jetzt ein paar kleine Spaßprojekte für winzig kleine Tools in Küstel geschrieben,
aber du rennst halt auch ständig dagegen, dass Libraries für grundlegende Dinge,
die in anderen Sprachen einfach kennenzulernen, einfach nicht existieren.
Und du kannst sie natürlich selbst schreiben oder du lässt es.
Und wenn du halt, das fand ich auch sehr schön, ich habe vor kurzem versucht,
ein bisschen mit Elixir anzufangen.
Und Elixir, geile Sprache, ohne Frage, ich möchte jetzt nicht viel darüber sagen,
weil ich mich ja nicht so gut damit auskenne, dass ich das im Kontext anderer Sprachen gut bewerten kann.
Aber Elixir hat den gigantischen Vorteil, dass es halt auf der Erlang-VM aufbaut
und du problemlos jeglichen Erlang-Code auch mit
callen kannst. Und da gibt es halt schon
ein Ecosystem, was seit Jahren existiert,
wo es diversen Code für
diverse Probleme einfach schon gelöst,
der halt da ist.
Und du kannst es einfach nutzen und du kannst
halt wirklich loslegen damit.
Und wie heißt es so schön im Englischen?
You can hit the ground running.
Im Vergleich zu Crystal an der Stelle.
Du kannst Probleme
lösen in Crystal, ja keine Frage. Und es macht
auch Spaß, diverse kleine Libraries für Dinge, die mir
fehlen, selbst zu implementieren, wo ich
da in Crystal-Tabler daran gescheitert bin, dass ich
den Crystal-JSON-Support unglaublich
umständlich fand und einfach nicht
hingekriegt habe, Custom-Typen in Custom-
JSON-Werte zu
serialisieren.
Das ist das, was man immer so wehtut.
Ja, genau, das ist überall schmerzhaft.
Ich wollte gerade mal nachgucken, Erlang
ist doch schon... Erlang ist doch von Sony Ericsson,
das ist doch gefühlt aus den 80ern, wenn nicht sogar älter.
86. Gut geschätzt.
86.
Das ist halt uralt, aber unglaublich stabil.
Erlang schreiben, finde ich, macht auch keinen Spaß.
Da habe ich mal ganz kurz probiert gehabt.
Was mich persönlich ein bisschen abgeschreckt hat,
war die simple Tatsache,
dass zum Beispiel, ich meine, das ist wie gesagt unglaublich simpel jetzt
und ein Erlang-Entwickler würde mir jetzt auch das als
sehr große Naivität anrechnen.
Aber ich fand es einfach ein bisschen hinderlich,
dass Erlang überhaupt keine Strings kennt.
Und du beschreibst
Strings immer als Liste
von Unicode Literal.
ist. Das ist halt ein bisschen
markelig. Du hast in Erlang ein Array
oder eine Liste oder was auch immer, wie du diesen Typen
gerade nennen möchtest, in Sprache deiner Wahl,
von fünf Zahlen, die irgendwo im
hunderter Bereich liegen und in Erlang printest du diese
Zahlenliste aus. Oh nee, warte, das sind zufällig
Char-Werte und die können jetzt übersetzt
werden und plötzlich ist es ein String.
Es gibt diese Unterscheidung gar nicht.
Und das fühlt sich hier wieder so ein bisschen dreckig an.
Das sieht das überhaupt nicht unterscheiden intern.
Du musst es halt wirklich manuell angehen.
Das fühlt sich an, als ob man da in komische
Probleme reinrennen könnte.
Ja, das klingt, als ob man da eine weitere Sprache oben drüber bügeln möchte, die das dann löst.
Ist das dann in Alexia schöner?
Ja, diese eine Problematik hast du zumindest nicht, wenn es überhaupt eine Problematik ist.
Ich habe jetzt nicht viel angeschrieben, wie gesagt, keine Ahnung, ob das eine Problematik ist für Leute, die da mehr drin schreiben.
Für mich schien es bloß anfangs so zu sein, sehr naiv betrachtet.
Ich finde das immer witzig, wenn du den Podcast, englische Podcasts anhörst, zum Beispiel Bike Chat.
Toller Podcast.
wenn die über Elixir reden.
Elixir, ja.
Das klingt komisch.
Ja, nee, das war eine Liederbetonung.
Ja, ich sag bloß,
das ist diese Aussprache,
wenn du tausendmal das mit dem Begriff Elixir gehört hast.
Und das machen wir auch mal,
wenn wir unsere englische Nullrunde reden.
Nehmen wir die gleiche Folge nochmal.
Wir schreiben uns jetzt quasi hinterher
die Themenreihenfolge auf,
machen ein Transcript
und dann unterhalten wir uns das gleiche Ding nochmal auf Englisch.
Also das ist jetzt gerade das Kapitel über Programmiersprachen
gewesen. Wenn du euch dafür einen Scheiß interessiert, dann spring doch bitte
direkt zum nächsten. Also da wir ja gute Kapitelmarken
haben werden, weil ich da selbst...
Müsst ihr bei den Kapiteln noch irgendwie so eine
Wertangabe machen
von 0 bis 5, wie technisch
das Thema?
Dass du sagen kannst, okay, und dann überspringe ich
bitte das Wert. Und dann gehst du bei deinem Podcast,
gerade bei Labo Podcast,
da gehst du quasi an, ich möchte
den ASCII-Cast hören, aber die ganzen
Programmiersprachen scheiße. Wie heißen denn
diese Diagramme, die wie so ein Spinnennetz aussehen,
wo du so in verschiedene Achsenrichtungen
gehen kannst und dann deine Interessen
in jede Richtung
definieren könntest. Und dann könntest du dein
persönliches Profil in deinem Podcast-Klein hinterlegen
und der kennt ja die Wertung
deiner Podcast. Kannst du aber so einen Musikdienst,
Pandora, war das Pandora, die das gemacht hat?
Pandora war dieser US-Radiodienst,
Streaming. Die haben quasi
so einen Graphen aus
Parametern zusammengestellt und haben
jedes Lied, was sie hatten, irgendwie
mit Werten von
traurig bis fröhlich bis schnell
bis langsam bis düster, keine Ahnung,
was das alles für Parameter waren
und haben jedem irgendwie so einen Wert zugewiesen
und dann konntest du halt Lieder
miteinander vergleichen und konntest sagen, okay, ich möchte
jetzt ein Lied haben, was etwa in das selbe Schema fällt.
Ich meine gerade für Radio, was ein Nutzer
sagen kann, ich möchte mehr von diesem Titel,
dann ist so ein System natürlich
sehr wertvoll, wo du das dann bewerten kannst.
Das ist mittlerweile alles tot. Pandora ist vor kurzem
erst gestorben, glaube ich, oder? Lieben die vielleicht sogar noch?
Die wurden von irgendwoher gekauft. Also Last.fm
kann man auch keine Musik mehr hören.
Last of M habe ich nie zum Musikhören genutzt.
Das war super. Du kannst sagen,
ich sag mir mal, du weißt jetzt
mittlerweile, deswegen habe ich ja immer geskoppelt,
sag mir mal andere Lieder oder andere
Künstler, die meinem Geschmack entsprechen,
aber die ich noch nicht kenne. Ja, aber das ist halt,
mein Geschmack wandelt sich halt auch über
Zeitrauben hier einfühlen. Wahrscheinlich ist es deshalb
auch irgendwie gestorben. Aber in Last of M
war eine super Datenbank von gehörter Musik.
Ich bereue es ein bisschen, Last of M nicht mehr zu nutzen,
weil ich einfach nur fürs Musikhören auf iTunes
umgestiegen bin und aus iTunes keine Möglichkeit.
Ich koppel immer noch, weil ich denke, ich lad mir einfach irgendwann
in 100 Jahren nach meiner gesamte Musikliste runter.
Es gibt diesen beschissenen Last.fm Desktop-Client,
der seit Urzeiten nicht geupdatet wurde.
Mit dem kannst du über iTunes skoppeln, aber ich will auch
vom Handy aus Musik hören und es geht einfach alles nicht.
Es ist alles scheiße.
Spotify kann skoppeln.
Das war das Schönste an Spotify.
Da muss mal jemand was programmieren.
Ich habe sogar schon angefangen, den iTunes-Kobbler zu schreiben.
Das habe ich dir letztens gezeigt auf dem Kongress,
der die Notifications von iTunes
und die im System propagiert werden
und die halt zu Last.fm schiebt.
Ah, nice. Aber das klappt ja noch nicht sauber.
Der Alternative zu Last of M war Libre.fm, oder?
Ja, aber das ist halt so eine Totgeburt schon gewesen.
Aber was war denn der Zweck davon?
Einfach auch bloß loggen, was ich höre?
Ja, genau. Und das halt nicht diesem
eigenen Service Last of M alles zu geben.
Das könnte man, da müsste ich ja, eigentlich wäre das ja
von Interesse für mich, das einfach mal selber zu hosten.
Einfach bloß, dass ich logge, was ich wann wie wo höre.
Macht das, warum nicht? Das Witzige an der
Implantation von Libre.fm war ja, dass die
genau dieselben API-Endpoint hatten
wie Last of M. Aber
Datei auf deinem System, Last.fm
zu Libre.fm rüber gebügelt und
somit haben die das alles aufgenommen. Und du musstest,
dein Client brauchte keine Unterstützung dafür, was eh keiner hatte.
Ich habe irgendeinen Client mal gesehen, der
Libre.fm hat. Wenn ich jetzt gucke, gibt es
eine
Library für meine Lieblingsprogrammiersprache,
weil ich da mal ein kleines Tool mitschreiben möchte
und dann gibt es das nicht und dann schaue ich mir an, wie die
Last.fm API aussieht.
Das habe ich dir,
ich fand die API, fand ich,
die Idee her unglaublich cool, weil die haben halt Authentication
gelöst, indem du deinen
API-Secret zusammen mit
allen Parametern, die du in einem Request
überschickt hast, alphabetisch sortiert
gehasht hast und diesen Hash mitgeschickt hast
und die haben das serverseitig nochmal verifiziert,
dass das auch korrekt ist.
Das fand ich...
Die API ist aus Zeiten, bevor man
API-Keys verteilt hat.
Du hattest ja einen API-Key und einen API-Secret und du hast beides
mitgeschickt. Und Secret hat
nur gehasht zusammen mit den anderen Parametern.
Das fand ich eine interessante Lösung dafür.
Ja klar, das ist... Es ist halt nur unheimlich umständlich
dafür kleinzuschreiben, weil du halt
klassisch hier zu hören, wie du im Python und dein Schreibt
kannst du nicht alles in den Diktum die einfach mitschicken,
weil die ja alphabetisch sortiert geherrscht werden müssen.
Also, oh Gott.
Ein bisschen
schwierig anzugehen, aber ich meine,
du kannst es so machen. Und meistens
gibt es halt, wie gesagt, eh schon die Kleidbibliothek deiner
Wahl für und dann nutzt du die einfach und
abstrichst du das weg und dann brauchst du dich gar nicht mehr drum kümmern.
Auf jeden Fall.
BlastFM ist eine tolle Sache.
Aber ich fühle mich auch immer so ein bisschen
eingeengt, wenn ich weiß, dass es im Hintergrund läuft.
Wenn ich weiß, ich skrubbel gerade alles, dann habe ich das Gefühl,
ich kann diesen Titel gerade nicht hören,
weil damit versaue ich mir meine Online-Bibliothek
und vor allem,
keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht, ob ich
im Detail drauf eingehen möchte.
Genau das Problem, ich habe letztens
daheim gesessen.
Die Leute sagen immer, ich habe doch nichts zu verbergen,
du änderst dein Verhalten, wenn du weißt, dass du überwacht wirst.
Ja, eben, du veränderst,
auch ganz subtil, oder halt eben nicht so
wie seit letztem daheim und wollte man einfach nur
das Spaßensalber von meinem Rechner aus
mit meiner Freundin daneben, Tokio Hotel
durch den Monsoon anmachen, aber erstmal
merkt, oh fuck, der Last of M-Client läuft noch,
den mache ich doch schnell mal aus, weil ich das nicht in meiner
Library haben möchte.
Du hast gerade auf Band gesagt, dass du neulich Bock auf Tokio Hotel hattest.
Oh ja.
Keine Ahnung.
Apropos Tokio,
ich wollte ja mal mit Tokio rumschwählen.
Tokio RS ist es aber jetzt und wieder weg zur
Rust-Welt. Da müsste man ja irgendwas Fieses bauen,
was man dann Tokio Hotel nennt.
Nenn einfach irgendeine Library Hotel,
die Tokio aufbaut und habt damit Spaß.
Naming ist immer schön.
So wie diese
Web Framework in Swift, was Taylor heißt,
dass du es einfach nicht googeln kannst. Gibt es das noch?
Es gibt sogar zwei
Swift-Dinge, die Taylor heißen. Die haben sich wahrscheinlich einfach gegenseitig nicht
gefunden, weil sie nicht Google-Baus sind. Das eine heißt
Taylor wie Taylor Swift und das andere
heißt Taylor wie Schneider, weil sie einfach daran
eingelehnt sind.
Wie ist der aktuelle Stand
von Web Frameworks in Swift?
Es gibt gefühlt drei, die gut sind.
Es gibt Perfect, ein
schlecht benanntes Ding, was anfangs rauskam,
also einer der ersten, fand ich ein bisschen hässlich,
aber ich bin nicht vertraut, wie die aktuell gebaut sind.
Es gibt Vapor, was unglaublich hübsch aussieht,
eine wunderschöne API hat.
Und die können einfach wunderschöne Dinge schreiben.
Hat auch eine CLI, um die Projekte zu generieren.
Und es gibt Ketura, Ketura geschrieben.
Das ist von IBM, weil IBM richtig...
K-I-T-U-R-A?
Ja, genau. K-I-T-U-R-A.
Daher das bei Apple alles Kit heißt?
Nee, nee.
Ketura ist, glaube ich, irgendwie ein Begriff in irgendeiner Sprache für Schwalbe.
Aber ich weiß es nicht.
Swift halt.
Es ist wieder was anderes rausgekommen, was Swift heißt.
Ja.
So ein Telefon.
Echt?
Ja, das ist so und so Swift.
Na toll.
Für diese endlose Liste an Dingen, die Swift heißen.
Dinge, die Swift heißen.
Eine Programmiersprache.
Ein Auto.
Noch eine Programmiersprache.
Ach stimmt, es gab ja diese Parallel Programming Language.
Internationale Bankenabkommen.
Musiker.
Chat-Clients.
Ach stimmt, die gibt es ja auch.
Swift-IM.
Na, hab ich voll vergessen.
Ja, genau.
kam Version 3.0 raus, ziemlich gleichzeitig
zu Apple Swift 3.0
und du hast dir gedacht, was hat
die für Features eingebaut?
Ja, das war leicht verwirrend.
Dann
OpenStack Swift.
Oh Gott.
Es gibt halt sehr viele Dinge, die Swift heißen.
Also ganz ehrlich, da hat sich
Apple wirklich ein Ei gelegt.
Vielleicht kam die Namensgebung von Chris Leibner
vorher.
Da hätte bei Apple irgendjemand sagen müssen,
mal davon abgesehen, dass es schon tausend
Sachen gibt, die nach Swift benannt sind, aber es gibt
halt schon eine andere Programmiersprache. Das hätte
der Tod dieses Namens sein.
Theoretisch. Was wären denn
andere alternative schöne Namen für Swift
gewesen? Wir fangen jetzt nicht an, hier irgendwie
Namen auszudenken. Wir haben nicht mal einen Namen für unseren eigenen
Podcast geschafft. Oh, Namen.
Ich habe gestern nochmal die
alte ASCII-Mailing-Liste,
über die der Verein gegründet
und organisiert wurde, seit 2007
durchgeschaut, weil wir dieses
Jahr zehn Jahre alt werden und ich eine
Einladungsmail an alle, die schon mal auf der
Mailingliste was geschrieben haben, rumschicken
möchte. Und da findest du
so Perlen wieder wie, ja, ich hab hier mal
ein paar Versionen
für ein potenzielles Logo vom Verein.
Und
findest du raus, wer das Logo gemacht hat. Und dann
ärgerst du dich, dass diese Mailingliste die
Dateien anhängen, nicht mitgespeichert hat.
Oh nein, wie traurig.
Ja, wir haben hier mal ein paar
alternative Namensvorschläge für unser
Kaffee durchdiskutiert. Geil.
Und dann hast du so eine Liste mit möglichen...
War es Unicode dabei?
Es war, glaube ich, ein Vorschlag wäre
Kaffee Digital gewesen,
damit es weiterhin CD heißt.
Ach so.
Weil es aus dem CD hervorgegangen ist.
Aber selbst das CD heißt ja noch CD.
Das CD gibt es ja auch nach wie vor,
aber das wäre ja komisch,
wenn das CD sich ausbildet in das CD und das CD.
Also kurze Erklärung,
es gab in der alten Fakultäne Informatik,
die 2005 umgezogen ist,
Ich hoffe, ich bin hier historisch korrekt.
Ich habe damals noch nicht studiert gehabt.
Und ich glaube, du auch noch nicht, oder?
Nein.
Das gab es das Café in dem Fakultät,
was gleichzeitig einer Club war.
Und das hieß Café oder Club Dürerstraße.
Club Dürerstraße.
Weißt du, was Dürerstraße war?
Genau.
Dann sind sie umgezogen.
Und das CD ist jetzt nicht mehr Club Dürerstraße,
sondern das Countdown, damit es nach wie vor CD heißt,
ist nach wie vor ein Studentenclub,
lebt in der Nähe der alten Fakultät.
aber das Fakultätsgebäude
ist halt weiter umgezogen
in Dresden und in der
Fakultät des Café,
was mit umgezogen ist, aber anfangs glaube ich
ein Jahr, ein halbes Jahr nicht existierte,
ist jetzt das ASCII. Vorher war das CD,
also das Counter und das ASCII eine Instanz,
jetzt sind es zwei.
Das ist diesen historischen Kontext, den ich
zumindest in der Form kenne.
Hallo, wir sind der
Studentenclub IZEV, wir würden gerne
einen Raum in der neuen Fakultät mieten, um
einen Kaffee aufzumachen. Also Studentenclubs,
nee, du meinst das Gehirn nicht machen.
Hier können wir keine Studentenclubs reinlassen.
Und dann haben sie sich, glaube ich,
nochmal gesammelt und ihre Strategie gewechselt
und haben nochmal angerufen und haben gesagt, schönen guten Tag,
wir sind die Studenteninitiative IZEV.
Ah, schönen guten Tag. Ja, wir würden gerne einen Raum
bei Ihnen nutzen, und zwar mit
unserer Studenteninitiative.
Und daraufhin mussten sie halt einen neuen Verein
gründen. Und jetzt gibt es der alte Verein,
der heißt offiziell
Studentenclub IZEV und der neue Club
heißt Studenteninitiative IZEV.
Oh Gott, das war mir gar nicht bewusst.
Aber ich meine, dass selbst das Prüfungsamt dafür weichen musste am Anfang.
Das Prüfungsamt war ja erst im Erdgeschoss da in unseren Räumlichkeiten.
Ja, das war dann nicht lange.
Aber doch, zumindest ein halbes Jahr, ja.
Und der Briefkasten vom Prüfungsamt hängt dort immer noch seit 2005.
Ja, ich musste da am Anfang, als ich angefangen habe, auch noch Zettel reinschmeißen.
Das ist, ich meine, das Gebäude wurde damals gebaut.
Der Briefkasten hängt dort seit Erbauen des Gebäudes.
Und der ist, glaube ich, seit 2009 zugeklebt.
Aber der ist doch deprecated seit einem halben Jahr danach, oder?
beziehungsweise vielleicht das Prüfungsamt
nochmal abgeholt.
Ich musste da noch ein paar Titel reinschmeißen.
Das ist ja bescheuert.
Das hat nichts damit zu tun, dass das Prüfungsamt da nicht mehr drin war.
Die haben das halt irgendwann abgeholt.
Der hängt trotzdem ja an der Wand.
Das ist ein riesiger Kasten.
Ich denke auch jedes Mal, wenn ich dran vorbeigehe,
was da noch alles drin liegt.
Leute, die da was reingeschmissen haben,
obwohl sie nicht...
Prüfungsanmeldungen.
Die Leute wundern sich, warum sind zu der Prüfung nicht zugelassen worden.
Die Leute, die vor acht Jahren
das da reingeschmissen hatten.
Ich warte immer noch auf die Wiederholungsgrüche.
Traurig. Es gibt ja diesen einen Studenten an der Fakultät,
der seit kurz vor der Wende
an der Uni studiert.
Alter. Den gibt es noch.
Und ich vermute auch, das ist einer der Gründe,
warum die aktuelle Studienordnung eine maximale Studiendose.
Kurz vor der Wende. Kurz vor der Wende.
Der hat in der DDR angefangen zu studieren.
Das heißt, der hat jetzt 60 Semester?
Ja. Aber ich meine,
der wird ja kein aktiver Student sein.
Der nutzt den Studentenstab einfach aus oder hat einfach nicht mitgekriegt,
dass er einen Dauerauftrag seitdem drin hat.
Wie schätzt er den Dauerauftrag?
Nee, das geht nicht, weil der Dauerauftrag muss ja den Betrag
regelmäßig anpassen.
Das kannst du ja nicht machen.
Vielleicht hat er auch was mit N26
programmiert.
Ja, die haben wir schon gehabt.
Jetzt wird jemand sein, der den Studentenstatus
gerne beibehält und halbtags
arbeitet. Keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht, wer
dieser Mensch ist. Keine Ahnung. Das würde mir die Uni
sicherlich auch nicht verraten.
Aber der könnte
unser Vater sein.
Ja.
Aber ich finde es großartig.
Vielleicht ist der noch Prof irgendwie.
Am Ende ist es irgendein Prof, der bald heute
reichst, der Student ist, damit er in der Mensa
billiger essen kann oder so. Und das rentiert
sich mit dem höchsten Beitrag,
weil er so oft in der Mensa isst.
Ja, voll der Hack.
Ja, aber es geht ja heutzutage nicht mehr.
Nee, der kann nicht Prof sein. Der hat ja dementsprechend noch keinen Abschluss.
Hm, good point.
Dann wirst du ja geäxt, sobald du irgendeinen Abschluss machst.
Good point. Da fliegst du ja raus.
Heutzutage wirst du ja geäxt, wenn du zu lange
da bleibst. Also du kannst ja nicht
aktuell 30 Jahre Student bleiben, so wie er.
das geht ja nicht mehr in der aktuellen Studienordnung.
Ach, eine Schande ist das.
Oh, wie traurig.
Ja, ja, nee.
Ich meine,
Maximaldauer da drauf zu schmeißen,
ist, glaube ich, schon nicht so blöd,
solange du damit nicht irgendwelche
legitimen Use Cases kaputt machst.
Aber 30 Jahre sollte man
nicht normalerweise Student bleiben können.
Das sehe ich, glaube ich,
schon ein, weil ich meine, 30 Jahre,
naja, können und sollen.
Ja, okay, da ist der große Unterschied.
Aber ich meine, wenn du 30 Jahre...
Wo legst du fest, wenn du jemandem sagst,
ich meine, die haben es gemacht,
aber woran legst du fest, wenn du jemandem sagst,
jetzt solltest du aber nicht mehr studieren?
Das ist eben das Schwierige,
aber nach 30 Jahren nutzt du das System als solches eher aus,
statt tatsächlich dich...
Ich meine, kann natürlich auch völlig legitim sein,
jemand, der Spaß daran hat.
Ja, vielleicht kommt der ja alle paar Semester mal wieder
und hört sich mal nochmal irgendeine neue Vorlesung an.
Oder er wechselt ständig durch
und macht irgendeine andere Vertiefung,
Studiengerichtung, was auch immer.
Das kannst du ja auch machen.
Was der mittlerweile für ein Pro sein muss.
Mein Dad, der ist Prof in Ingolstadt und der hatte vor, ich glaube, ein paar Jahre her,
hatte er einen Studenten, der war 42 Jahre alt, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht,
der war Testpilot bei der Bundeswehr und ist in die Frührente gegangen mit 40
und meinte, er fängt einfach mal ein Studium an und hatte, glaube ich, im Laufe dessen,
wenn ich mich nicht immer alles täusche, ich wüsste nicht, wie ich das verifizieren sollte,
mehrere Studiengänge durch und hatte einfach Spaß dran,
sich in der Richtung im Unikontext eben vorzubilden.
Ja, super. Das ist auch großartig, das ist fantastisch.
Also wenn ich irgendwann kommen würde, du musst jetzt auch mal Geld verdienen, dann hätte ich das auch weiter gemacht.
Auf der anderen Seite, die Art und Weise, wie du das Wissen an der Universität vermitteln, wird es halt auch deutlich langsam.
Das ist stark suboptimal.
Ja, also es hängt halt vom Themenbereich ab.
Ich meine, gerade bei der Kenntnis, vor allem aus der Informatik eben, da bist du als Autodidakt zehnmal schneller unterwegs.
Ja, es funktioniert halt, wenn du ein großes Spektrum dir reindrücken musst, was du sonst nicht freiwillig machen würdest.
Weil du hörst ja die ersten, du hörst ja
zehn Vorlesungen gleichzeitig zu
komplett unterschiedlichen Themen und da kannst du nicht
alles auf einmal sofort so reinziehen.
Aber wenn ich jetzt anfangen würde und ich würde
sagen, oh, ich gehe nochmal in die Informatikfakultät,
ich möchte mich jetzt mit künstlicher Intelligenz
auseinandersetzen,
da kannst du dir nicht eine Vorlesung anhören, weil du hörst
einmal in der Woche eine 90-Minuten-Vorlesung
und denkst dir so, und jetzt?
Und dann wartest du eine Woche auf die nächste.
Gab es da nicht auch diesen Podcast, der random
Vorlesungsmitschnitte einfach veröffentlicht hat?
Es gibt von der Radio Wissen den Hörsaal.
Das ist ein sehr, sehr
empfehlenswerter Podcast. Die haben einfach
bloß jedes Mal
irgendeinen Spezialvortrag von irgendeinem Prof
oder von irgendeinem Dozenten.
Das ist quasi eine digitale Ringvorlesung.
Cool. Das ist geil.
Und da hast du die Themen auch sehr gut zugeschnitten
und gekapselt in einem Vorlesungsformat.
Das ist...
Ja, das ist immer was komplett Unabhängiges
vom Nächsten. Manchmal sind es auch
Gesprächsrunden zu aktuellen Themen.
Eine Folge war zum Beispiel
zum Thema von einem
Akustiker oder Musikwissenschaftler
zum Thema Stimmentwicklung
und der hat einen Vortrag gehalten
über den Stimmbruch von Musikern.
Zum einen, als er hat
ein Beispiel von Justin Bieber
mit Klangbeispielen von
vor dem Stimmbruch und nach dem Stimmbruch.
Aber auch zum Beispiel, das fand ich sehr spannend,
mit Leonard Cohen
oder Bob Dylan.
Okay.
Du hast zwei Stimmbrüche.
Du hast, zumindest als Typ, als Frau hast du immer einen einen.
Und zwar den halt am Anfang, wenn du groß wirst.
Dem am Anfang, wenn du groß wirst.
Den Stimmbruch, den alle kennen, wo du plötzlich eine tiefere Stimme bekommst.
Aber du hast um Mitte 50 bis 60 noch einen Stimmbruch.
Wo dann der Whisky und das Rauchen langsam einschlägt.
Wo du eine alte Herrenstimme kriegst.
Der hat Klangbeispiele von Bob Dylan.
oder Leonard Cohen vorgespielt, wo sie plötzlich
halt nochmal eine halbe Oktave tiefer
gesungen haben, weil sie halt eine viel, viel tiefere
Stimme bekommen haben. Spannend.
Das klingt mir echt spannend. Du hast auch so krasse
Beispiele von dem Sänger von Aha, der
immer extrem hoch gesungen hat. Das schafft er heute
nicht mehr. Die müssen halt die ganzen
Lieder irgendwie einen halben Ton, ein bisschen Ton oder zwei Töne
runternehmen, damit das noch, damit
er den Bereich noch erreicht.
Das ist sowas, was du bei dir Radio wissen.
Das ist ein sehr, sehr guter Radio. Ich soll dich auch mal
abonnieren, den Podcast zu mir wissen.
Auch das Update. Ich höre eigentlich meine Nachrichten
eigentlich nur noch, indem ich mir dieses Update
um 18 Uhr als Podcast abonniert habe.
Das Schöne an D-Radio-Wissen ist,
es ist ein konventionaler Radiosender.
Ich habe eine Zeit lang Detektor FM gehört,
aber ich brauche tatsächlich,
wenn ich zum Beispiel morgens aufstehe und Radio höre,
brauche ich so ein bisschen jemand,
der mir was erzählt.
Dieses dumme Gelaber von den ganzen Standard-Radiosendern
wie Jump und was weiß ich.
Das kann man sich nicht geben.
das ist bei der Radio Wissen,
da hast du auch Moderatoren-Bongs,
aber was die dir erzählen und worüber die
reden, das ist schon wesentlich interessanter und die haben halt
Nachrichten um
zur vollen Stunde und
zur halben Stunde, ganz normal,
immer großer Nachrichtenblock, kleinerer Nachrichtenblock
und dann haben sie noch einen extra Nachrichtenblock
um drei Viertel, das sind die Wissensnachrichten.
Und das sind dann
Tippbits aus der
Forschung, aktuelle Veröffentlichung
und Studienergebnisse und sowas.
Das ist total geil.
Ich glaube, ich höre von D-Radio, wir wissen nur den
100-Podcast, weil der so ein bisschen
aneinander, der ist schon vom Format her
so eine Art deutsches Radio-Labs, so ein bisschen Storytelling.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. In 100 Minuten, glaube ich,
ist der Gimmick da, wenn ich mich nicht alles täusche.
Oder eine Stunde History.
Also hört euch mal die ganzen
Sendungen von Detection.
Wir müssen mal ein paar Podcast-Empfehlungen von uns
irgendwo veröffentlichen. Komm, wir haben eine Stunde geschafft.
Wir listen jetzt noch ein paar, wir hören jetzt hier auf
und listen noch ein paar Podcasts auf, die ihr jetzt
im Anschluss hören könnt.
Okay, schwierig. Wir nehmen in meinem iPhone auf, da sind meine Podcasts drauf.
Okay, fang du an. Ich überlege mir, was mir einfällt.
Also, wir haben schon aufgezählt.
99% Invisible.
Ja, starkes Plus auch von mir.
Radiolab.
Ja, Empfehlung.
D-RadioWissen.
Oh Gott, was höre ich noch?
Die ganzen Gimlet-Podcasts finde ich auch großartig.
Gimlet ist so eine...
Es hat angefangen mit einem Podcaster, einem Startup, der verfolgt Firmen in ihrer Entwicklungsphase,
meistens so seasonmäßig, ich würde immer komisch Podcasten, Seasons zu splitten, aber die machen das halt.
Eine Season ist eine Firma, sie verfolgen eine Firma und versuchen so viel wie möglich in den Hintergründen auch von den blöden Details,
die du eigentlich nicht über deine Firma anfangs in den Babyschuhen veröffentlichen möchtest und nehmen da halt so viel wie möglich auf.
Und das Witzige ist, die erste Staffel von Startup verfolgte die Firma selber, die diesen Podcast produziert hat.
Die wussten anfangs nicht mehr, wie sie hießen.
Das war ein Typ namens Alex Bloomberg, der bei NPR gearbeitet hat.
Der hat lange bei Planet Money eben den Host gespielt und bei anderen Podcasts.
Und hat eben dann seine eigene Firma, sein eigenes Podcast unternehmen.
Wir sind ein bisschen blöd in dem Kontext, aber er hat seine eigene Firma gründen wollen.
Die heißen jetzt Gimlet Media.
Der eigenerste Podcast von Gimlet Media war eben der Startup.
Und haben direkt weitergemacht mit Reply All, ein Podcast über das Internet.
Manchmal ein bisschen anstrengend zuzuhören, aber meistens recht unterhaltsam.
Ein Podcast über das Internet.
Ja, ist halt sehr breit gefächert und die sind halt sehr oft auch so diese Themen, die ein bisschen an mir vorbeigehen, wie Harambe, diesen Affen, der da gestorben ist und ich vernage mich fest auf komische Details, die ich eh keine Ahnung habe, aber es ist trotzdem unterhaltsam und die haben mittlerweile ein großes Repertoire an sehr guten Podcasts und ich höre sie fast alle und meinte, die sind leider auch schon wieder weggestorben.
Mystery-Podcast. Ich fand den großartig.
Da gab es leider nur die erste Staffel von, wo es umging,
in jeder Folge ein Mysterium,
was völlig unrealistisch
schien lösbar zu sein,
komplett zu lösen. Kann man sich
die Folgen noch anhören? Ich glaube, die sind alle online.
Die kriegst du auch alle in dem...
Nicht, dass das so wie
Hardcore History verschwindet.
Ja, aber Gimlet macht ein paar super tolle Podcasts
und die sind auch qualitativ hochwertig,
sehr, sehr hochwertig und da würde ich einfach mal,
es sind nicht so viele, dass man keinen Denenüberblick verliert,
einfach mal durchschauen und was vom Thema her
sagen, klingt einfach durchabonnieren. Wenn du gerade von Mystery
redest, es gibt noch einen deutschen Podcast, der heißt
Hoaxzilla. Oh, den habe ich jetzt ein paar
Folgen mal gehört gehabt, auf deine Empfehlung hin. Genau, die
sind auch in letzter Zeit, machen die nur noch
sehr wenig Folgen, aber die haben schon einen Stockpile
von 200 Folgen und die fangen immer
damit an, die haben auch schön,
die sind ein schön strukturierter Podcast, das ist so
ein Ehepärchen, sind so
zwei Gothics, wenn man sich die
mal so anguckt und die haben sich vorgenommen,
die sind halt Skeptiker oder
haben angefangen
sich Skeptiker zu nennen, aber mögen den Begriff mittlerweile
so sehr, weil Skeptiker sind auch Leute auf der Straße,
die nicht daran glauben, dass die Erde rund ist
und sowas.
Die möchten also die wissenschaftliche Methode
auf Hoaxes anwenden und dann nehmen sie sich immer
so Urban Myths oder irgendwelche Sachen,
wo die Leute glauben, oder halt tatsächlich
Gruselgeschichten, also manchmal sind die Gefolge richtig gruselig
und die fangen halt erst damit an,
diese Geschichte und diesen Hoax komplett zu erzählen
und zu erläutern und zwar auf eine Art und Weise,
als ob das wirklich so ist und dann versetzt man sich
super rein, das ist immer so meistens so die erste halbe Stunde
und dann, wenn sie dir was über
Slenderman erzählen, das kannst du nicht
zum Einschlafen hören.
Dieses Spiel, ich wusste gar nicht, dass es noch mehr drum herum gibt.
Das ist halt, oder irgendwelche
so japanische
Spurgeschichten, so wie diese
Geschichte, die sich Leute erzählen, auf der
der Film The Grudge basiert.
Und da wusste sie sich schon
so ein bisschen, und dann fangen sie an,
das methodisch zu zerlegen und
dir aufzuzählen, warum das halt nicht geht
und wo dieses, vor allem sie
ist, ich glaube, Kulturwissenschaftlerin
oder Literaturwissenschaftlerin.
Und sie zerlegt dann auch die kulturellen
und literarischen Hintergründe dieser Hoax.
Da gibt es am Anfang eine Story der Woche,
wo du einen raten musst, ist das wahr oder ist das nicht wahr?
Und das wird dann erst zum Schluss aufgelöst.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich schön produziert.
Das ist ein guter Podcast.
Ich kenne, wie gesagt, keine aktuellen Folgen.
Ich habe nur mal welche irgendwann
vor einem Jahr oder vor zwei gehört.
Aber die hatten mir gefallen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich die abonniert habe.
Ich glaube nur, weil kein neuer Content kam und ich dachte, der sei tot.
Man kann sich immer die alten Folgen noch anhören.
Stimmt.
stimmt. Ansonsten ein Podcast, der mir jetzt gerade
einfällt, der auch sehr gut ist, ist etwas
komplett anderes, No Such Thing Is A Fish.
Der ist ein Podcast, der von
ein paar Mitarbeitern der
fantastischen britischen Fernsehserie
QI, stehen für Quite Interesting,
produziert wird.
Die Fernsehserie, wer sie kennt, wer sie nicht
kennt, ist letztendlich bloß eine Ansammlung
von lustigen Fakten,
interessanten Fakten mit typischen
bekannten britischen Promis,
Promis ist ein sicherer Begriff,
bekannten britischen Persönlichkeiten,
die eher auf sehr lustige Art und Weise so ein bisschen als Quizshow
gebracht wird.
Eine lange von Stephen, wie heißt er?
Ja.
Oh Gott, Stephen Fry, danke.
Stephen Fry produziert seit der aktuellsten Staffel
nicht mehr.
Das hat er aufgehört.
Tolle Serie, muss gar nicht weiter drauf eingehen,
würde man sich mal anschauen.
So eine Panel-Show, dem Begriff, wenn man was sagt.
Und die Mitarbeiter dahinter, die die Facts raussuchen,
die in der Serie rankommen,
die haben eben auch ihren eigenen Podcast,
wo sie viele der Facts, die eben nicht eine Rolle spielen
in QI, einfach sich erzählen und
lustig machen oder drüber
reden. Und es einfach nur ein Runterrattern
von lustigen Fakten mit viel drumherum.
Also ich bin immer fasziniert, wie das
ineinander verzahnt. Wenn dann irgendwie
nach dem dritten Fakt jemand noch
eine Anspielung auf einen der ersten macht.
Ich weiß noch nicht, wie sehr sie sich darauf vorbereiten.
Oft erscheint es sich wahrscheinlich,
also es sind vier
Leute, es sucht sich jeder einen
Fakt der Woche aus. Ich schätze mal, dass sie sich
vorher die Sachen geben, dass sie sich so ein bisschen auch
auseinander. Aber teilweise auch nicht.
Teilweise wissen sie nicht viel.
Vielleicht geben sie bloß eine grobe Idee, von welcher Richtung
der Fakt geht.
Das kann natürlich auch sein.
Aber es ist ein sehr guter Podcast und
macht unglaublich viel Spaß. Ist auf Englisch natürlich.
Ist ein britischer Podcast mit viel Großbritannien.
No such thing as a fish.
Wo die Geschichte, wo das
herkommt, haben sie glaube ich noch
Folge 1. In Folge 1
kommt das nicht vor. Dann war es
eine Folge QI.
Die Grundidee ist, dass
wenn du im Oxford English Dictionary
Fish nachschaust, dann steht da
No Such Thing as a Fish.
Also es gibt nichts, was ein Fish ist.
Und es ist einfach so ein witziges,
weil irgendwas, ich weiß nicht mehr.
Weil es zu generisch ist.
Ich glaube sowas war, ich habe es auch nicht mehr genau im Kopf.
Müsst ihr auch nochmal nachschauen, wo das genau herkommt.
Aber so heißt der Podcast zumindest.
Sehr, sehr unterhaltsam.
Jede Folge heißt dann No Such Thing as a
und dann irgendwas, was gerade Thema ist.
Stimmt, stimmt.
Also auch sehr gut.
Ansonsten höre ich sehr gerne, schon erwähnt
vorher, den Accidental Tech Podcast von
drei Personen, auf die ich sehr viel gebe, auf der Meinung ich sehr viel gebe.
Marco Arment, Casey List und John Syracusa.
Auch gut.
Surprisingly Awesome.
Der ist von Gimlet. Das ist ein Gimlet.
Das ist ein Gimlet Podcast.
Surprisingly Awesome.
Der eine Typ, die zwei Hosts, der eine von
den beiden ist Regisseur von
lustigen Filmen.
Was hat denn der gemacht? Irgendwann sehr bekannt.
The Big Short ist von dem.
Ach so.
Nicht gerade ein Low-Budget-Kleiner-Unbekannter-Film,
sondern ein ziemlich großer, bekannter Film.
Und der Regisseur ist halt einer der Co-hosts
von Surprisingly Awesome, passanterweise.
Abgefahren.
Die Leute, die Podcasts machen, die haben ja alle noch
ein Privatleben und ein eigentliches
Hauptbroterwerb. Es ist ja nicht jeder so ein...
Ich glaube, ein Podcastleben, das können die wenigsten.
So ein Tim Pridlaw vielleicht.
Oder so ein Mike Hurley aus der
englischsprachigen Welt.
Oder so ein Lea Laporte.
Von dem höre ich aber überhaupt nichts.
Billionie reingekommen, das ist so gar nicht meine Welt.
Nee, aber ich hab, als ich in den USA war,
hab ich halt immer
auf TechTV The Screensavers geguckt und
die sagen,
da hab ich so ein bisschen Nostalgie verspürt, als ich das
hier das im ersten Mal. Ich hab dann The New Screens
ein, zwei Mal geguckt, das ist halt tatsächlich
wie früher, aber
es ist ganz hübsch, aber es ist tatsächlich eine Fernsehsendung.
Die ganzen Netcasts,
die sind auch alle mit Video,
die kannst du dir halt auch ohne Video angucken.
Bei vielen funktioniert's,
bei manchen funktioniert's gar nicht, weil sie sagen,
wie man jetzt hier sieht,
und dann bist du auf einem Podcast,
irgendwo sitzt du an der Straße,
und da denkst du,
was soll ich denn jetzt sehen?
Kannst du die Shownotes schauen,
vielleicht ist dein Bild verlinkt,
aber meistens...
Und bei Security Now
sind die Shownotes eine PDF,
die irgendwo bei dem einen Host
auf der eigenen Webseite liegen.
Oh, natürlich.
Wie veröffentlicht man eigentlich Shownotes?
Ich kenne bloß diese Plattform
shownote.es,
wo community-driven
Shownotes existieren,
aber die...
Shownotes sind quasi
der accommodating
Blogpost in deinem WordPress.
Ich dachte,
ich kann die irgendwie mit
3 embedden oder in den Feed zum Beispiel
mit... Das gehört mir in den Feed rein.
In den Feed embedden, damit der Client das mit anzeigt. Also mein Podcast
Client zeigt die auch an, wenn ich runterscrolle
auf der Coverart. Und das nutzt ja auch
sehr gerne das Feed. Das ist ja ein RSS-Feed mit einem Inhalt
und ich schätze mal, die Schleunen sind da mit drin.
Ach so, sind die... Ah! Das ist quasi... Das ist
ein Blogpost. Ich meine, logisch.
Ich meine, du kannst ja einfach den Feed dann
veröffentlichen mit der angehängten Mediendatei und
dann ist ja alles da, was du brauchst als Information.
Ja. Wir müssen uns mal mit
Bloghosting-Software auseinandersetzen. Ich dachte
eigentlich, wir machen den einfachen Weg,
einen stupiden Weg und vermeisen die Sounddatei hier einfach
auf Soundcloud. Und wie regt man da
Sachen an?
Ich weiß nicht, wie du eben die schonnest.
Keine Ahnung, also das weiß ich nicht.
Also ich habe von den Leuten, die
sind ja auch nicht zu blöd zum selber hosten,
daran sollst du ja nicht scheitern. Von den Leuten, die
Podlove, vorhin heißt das noch Podlove,
diese Initiative,
gab es halt auch immer
schöne Kritik zum Thema, oh jetzt kann man das
auch auf Soundcloud machen, aber auf Soundcloud
ist das eigentlich nicht geil. Ich meine, das einzige
Problem, was ich damit hätte, ist, wenn es eben kein
gibt. Aber solange es diesen RSS-Feed gibt, ist das ja
immer noch so offen. Ich kriege
halt nur zusätzlich diese Möglichkeit.
Du musst halt in den RSS-Feed selber noch
Metadaten als zusätzliche Text hinzufügen können.
Das kann halt sein, dass du bei Soundcloud keine
Kapitelmarken hinzufügen kannst.
Die Kapitelmarken hängen immer in der MP3-Datei mit drin.
Achso.
Die embedde ich direkt in das MP3-Datei rein.
Faszinierend.
Daran soll es nicht scheitern.
Es sei denn, Soundcloud rechnen wir die raus, was ich extrem
kacke fände, aber auch nicht vermute,
dass das der Fall ist.
Also was ich vorhin gemacht habe, war bloß ein bisschen,
also vorhin als einzige Vorbereitung
auf diesem Podcast, ich habe mir die MP3-Datei
10 Sekunden aufgenommen, kurz in- und hergeschnitten,
Kapitelmarken reingepackt und mir das Ganze in meine
Podcast abgeschmissen, um zu schauen, wie
das ausschaut und ob das richtig ist, was ich vermute,
was da passiert. Und das hat zumindest geklappt, aber ich habe es nicht
versucht, hier aus Soundcloud hochzuladen,
weil ich dafür, nee, keine Ahnung, aber ich habe es
nicht versucht hochzuladen und das darüber abzuspielen
und den RSS-Feed einzubetten.
Ja, mal schauen, worauf wir uns zum Schluss festlegen.
Werden wir in der nächsten Folge sicherlich erzählen.
meine Mate ist so gut wie leer.
Deine noch nicht. Ja, ich glaube, wir müssen das Ganze auch noch mal
wie Anhörer und Nachbar arbeiten. Ja, wir können ein bisschen
Kram rausreien, vielleicht auch nicht.
Wird sich zeigen, je nachdem, ich meine, ich habe gar nicht gesagt, wie lange
der aktuell ist.
Ich glaube, wir sagen an dieser Stelle dann mal Tschüss.
Das war eine spaßige erste Folge.
Das war eine spaßige erste Folge. Das Spannende wird jetzt,
was haben wir jetzt für die nächste Folge tangiert,
noch übrig gelassen.
Wir werden uns immer über irgendwas unterhalten können und vermute,
ein ähnliches Format werden die Folgen von jetzt auch noch haben.
Vielleicht entwickelt sich das irgendwann in eine andere Richtung.
Vielleicht gehen wir auf Current Events mit ein.
wir können gerne immer noch mit
dran schreiben, auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10
wie techy die Episode geworden ist
einfach so unsere Syntax dafür überlegen
in eckigen Klammern hinter jedes Kapitel
auf einer Skala von 1 bis 5
genau
also 1
Vorsicht, diese Folge kann Spuren von
Programmiersprachen rumnörden enthalten
ich meine, ich höre auch sehr gerne solche Podcasts
es wäre ja auch völlig legitim, sowas zu haben
klar, ich weiß es nicht
Würde deine Freundin einen Podcast über
Programmiersprachen hören?
Ich glaube tatsächlich ja.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie die Kapitel dann auch irgendwann
überspringen wird. Gut, okay, ich muss jetzt dazu sagen,
deine Freundin studiert auch Informatik.
Das habe ich jetzt gerade nicht im Hinterkopf gehabt.
Aber ich kann
es nicht, ich will es einfach ihr nicht wegnehmen,
diese Entscheidung. Ich weiß es nicht, wie sie sich entscheiden
würde an der Stelle, aber das spielt auch nicht so eine Rolle.
Meine Mom würde es so nicht machen. Meine Mom würde aber auch
generell keine Podcasts hören.
Meine Mom hat sehr viele Hörbücher. Vielleicht würde sie sogar
einen Podcast hören.
Meine Oma würde tatsächlich diesen Podcast
unter keinen Umständen nur zu ever hören.
Die Oma liest sehr viele E-Books aber zur Zeit.
Wenn wir das Transkript als E-Book
vollkommen. Ja, also an dieser Stelle schönen Gruß an
Köln-Jans Oma.
Wir haben jetzt
eine Stunde zwanzig geschafft.
Und ja, wir sollten das an der Stelle wirklich machen.
Wow, du hörst immer noch zu.
Erstaunlich, ich hau mich weg.
Ja, dann vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit.
Vielen, vielen Dank und mal schauen,
wann es weitergeht.
Wir freuen uns auf die nächste Folge.
Wir freuen uns über Namensvorschläge,
wenn wir bei der nächsten Folge noch keinen haben.
Wir freuen uns über eure
Podcast-Empfehlungen.
Podcast-Klein-Empfehlungen.
Programmiersprachen-Empfehlungen.
Und Themenvorschläge.
Themenvorschläge sind cool. Mal schauen, ob wir überhaupt
einen Hörer finden für die erste Folge. Für die Nullrunde.
Für die 0. Folge. Wäre cool.
Deine Freundin wird es hören, oder?
Bestimmt. Also dann macht es gut.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Hat Spaß gemacht.
Hat Spaß gemacht. Bis dann. Bleibt sexy.